frédéric à poser
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous c'est un prime
exceptionnelle qu'on va vous présenter
dans l'instant il y aura camille combal
qui va démarrer cette émission il a
toutes les images 2d 8 pendant trois ans
il a déroché je pense qu'on va on va se
faire une rigolade y aura de l'enfant de
star tout de suite pour démarrer vous
allez voir toutes les images qui nous
ont fait rire sur d8 et puis bien sûr il
y aura des défis il y aura des choses
qui vont se passer dans cette émission
des choses folles déjà dans un instant
on ira chercher quelqu'un en régie qui
va partir en camion avec différents de
personnes il ne sait pas où il va partir
mais vous verrez je pense que ça va lui
faire plaisir mais vous pouvez pas
démarré cette émission sans prendre une
photo une photo de famille normale de
tous les animateurs de débit tous ses
admirateurs que vous avez aimé pendant
trois ans leur nom prendra la photo à la
fin nous ensemble avec des invités mais
eux ils vont faire la photo de départ
regarder sont tous en place au dessus
quand pour la photo n'offre à la faute
[Applaudissements]
non content du résultat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
taux
oh bah ouais
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'e3 les bons termes et au plafond
chéri capitaux
[Applaudissements]
il va enfin voir cette émission merci
voilà y aura même pas jay directo
démarre direct la gym salle assez bon et
c'est là le problème c'est le laisser le
revenu est venu en plateaux vallon va
accueillir tous les chroniqueurs qui ont
fait leur part avec nous ce soir
ça me roy
dommage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et mathieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous on va démarrer
cette émission il aura la question en
4/3 bien sûr à la fin de l'émission jean
luc lemoine sera là merci gérard et
thibaut place aux gens arrêtés pour cela
je sais pas si je suis là je sais pas à
qui vous voulez toute façon je vous
dirais que la police était bis à
l'époque habib combat le monde et marc
cette émission mon chéri on va revenir
sur les trois bandes est vite mais juste
avant il y a des enfants de stars c'est
parti on évite enfants de serre avant de
revenir sur ces deux trois ans des
missions sur des beats un enfant de star
pour fêter le retour ce soir de gérard
louvin bien sûr puisque gérard pont qui
n'étaient pas dans tp pendant une saison
il s'est beaucoup amusé gerra il a
notamment eu une aventure avec une
grande star de la variété
madonna les amis gérard louvin et
madonna a eu un enfant et elle aime le
jeu comme son père je vous le dis on l'a
retrouvé sur la télé regardez vous avez
mis au monde
beaucoup d'enfants beaucoup dans les
combien d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
ce soir tout au long de l'émission ce
sera l'occasion d'ouvrir le grimoire de
l'histoire de débit oui mais bon c'est
trois en trois ans de passion de
concours de barbecue aussi rôle c'est
alors juste à l'heure du bilan on va le
faire calmement une histoire quand même
qui a commencé il ya trois ans jour pour
jour aller lancement de la chaîne ah oui
ça rappelle le lancement de la chaîne
pierre vous étiez là il y aura des
contes exceptionnel mais magnifique a
elle même eu un problème de sous dès le
premier jour y'a tout animé par un cyril
et laurence ferrari bon on peut parler
de danger soufflage et pratiquants mais
on veut on vous allez rentrer l'autre
l'instant on dirait que c'est une boîte
de nuit s'y attendait allez-vous changer
allez-vous changer j'y vois là je
roulais l'arrière sylvain agile balle à
carreaux
voilà bah merci gilles pas là
[Applaudissements]
j'y suis d'accord avec un nouveau
classique
voilà voilà total va revenir sur les
trois ans deux des huit cas mais ça vous
va très bien comme ça vraiment bravo
gilles bravia quinconces et toutes ont
baissé
[Applaudissements]
alors on utilisa lancement que j'aime ça
commence toujours mais voilà par un
décompte par un grand moment historique
pour une chaîne et nous c'était le plus
raté de l'histoire de la télé des ponts
coupés problèmes techniques
la fermeture de la 5 et est plus réussie
que notre langue notre attention on est
à dix secondes ou à faire le décompte
ensemble c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voulait on n'a jamais compris que lens
bordeaux lâche rien qui marche et rien
du tout et parmi des émissions phares de
la chaîne il ya bien sûr eu alors plein
plein de choses mais notamment la
nouvelle star vous le savez animer
pendant deux ans par le plus mélomanes
d'entre nous sait rire ah ah
et cette émission nous a appris que sert
il a des problèmes de vue on le savait
pas on l'a appris il est obligé de
porter des lunettes problème visiblement
hésitez pas du tout à sa vue le budget
parce que cyril a passé deux ans à ce
pot mais sur le plateau de la nouvelle
star
il avait déjà du mal à trouver son
chemin pour cent du plateau rhdp vous
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était pas par là mais c'est pas
tout cyril a aussi d'autres problèmes et
je vous rassure
au bout d'un moment il connaît c'est
vraiment le plateau comme sa poche il
disparaît à la ninja du palu allez voir
c'est impressionnant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les vols vers ce que le gars est
complètement et c'est un non pas la
balle alors regardez regardez la
tristesse du gala il veut faire le malin
non je vais quand même pas la voile
assez forte comme sa poche avec ses
problèmes de ville a été handicapé
pendant tous les frags de la nouvelle
star cyril à tel point que en vrai voilà
ils posaient des questions dont les
réponses paraissait pour nous soit
téléspectateurs assez évidente a quand
même faut dire alors ce sans jamais
regarder ça s'est vu
est ce que vous allez voir du conflent
de trois indices qui me disent qu'ils
sont venus pour slogan faites moi qui
les ai vus mais visiblement il voyait
rien de prêt non plus ou alors il est
daltonien cyril et ça c'est les lunettes
peuvent rien faire pour lui l'eau
philippe fo n'ont regardé les 3 6 3 6 0
pour un prix non merci j'ai et merci
d'avoir un couloir a pas de ça les mecs
les mecs c'est bon là on a d'autres
choses qui vont arriver manque allumés
juste avant parce que vous reste avec
moi il ya plein de choses de l'image de
camille on voudrait qu'on aille chercher
le patron de davy de celle au directeur
général de des 8 xavier gandon en régie
il ya des amis qui vont aller le
chercher en régie je crois qu'on a une
caméra voilà qui est prête et xavier
gandon voilà alors ils regardent
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a cru
le patron le patron jade et guesdon va
partir avec la compagnie gueule et on va
le retrouver
non c'est mon meilleur combat de
retrouver on va le retrouver à banana
[Applaudissements]
non
balma c
commence alors c'est le grand patron de
but il va sortir car c'est son
anniversaire c'est lui le patron de
démanteler trois ans c'est vous qui avez
trois ans que saviez grande eau voilà
bah ouais ça et mon clavier vous allez
partir avec toute la compagnie créole
vous allez voir alors on devrait avoir
honte d'avoir un quart et je vous jure
un minivan et le minivan est tombé en
panne
[Applaudissements]
comme jamais on a fait nos 10 ailleurs
il est tombé en panne le minivan donc
vous allez partir avec une estafette
cependant à trouver un truc je vous jure
que c'est vrai et vous allez voir vous
allez avec la compagnie créole vous
allez être je peux pas vous dire avec
quoi mais il va avoir des trucs très
très bizarre dans le don de la piste a
fait on va vous retrouver dans 5 à 10
minutes dans les cela fait vous ne savez
pas où vous allez mais ce que je leur
conseillais métal métal ou apparemment
c'était pas le look jean luc lemoine
parce qu'il a une petite tête
bon à la barre de c'est pourquoi rester
comme ça ja des gones au port avec la
conquête
[Applaudissements]
l'autre avocat local basse et sa
richesse
à cette époque là et vous allez vous
rendre dans un instant mes chéris
conseil régaler nos patrons si vous
faites les missions de vous alors vous
savez qu'on ait quatre est trop quand
même
[Musique]
mais moi je suis au milieu et epub les
doigts
il était périmé alors attention le bus
va aller non mais on va le retrouver
dans un instant laisser buisson à
l'instant où ils avaient grandi et
ballet chérie je vais m'occuper de vous
à la cause
pour l'instant on a eu des missions à
faire on voulait faire des photos mais
nous ça voulait faire les fanfarons à
faire une photo sera moins ce qu'ont
fait les photos on ne voulait pas de
choc
merci tu dis moi ce qu'on peut enlever
le sont là parce que on a l'impression
sans rigoler cas le tramway à côté
d'autres directement dehors mais ça
vient directement de la bbc steve austin
où il a l'oeil sur lui portant de
quelqu'un péter animaux
[Musique]
c'est à limoges c'est à limoges c'est
c'est roger roger da silva au par le
club de nouvelle star et on veut pas
parler dernier rival ou la nouvelle star
sans la fameuse tête de suspense parce
que cyril quand il est stressé on ne
sait pas pourquoi ça bouge disparaît et
on a mis quelques unes des meilleures
dans ces disparitions buccale
inexpliquée à ne pas reproduire chez
vous les enfants c'est important
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à cause de toi c'est n'importe
quoi
[Applaudissements]
et franchement vous remercier tous les
soirs mais tpp est de plus en plus de
fans 12 à nous suivre chaque jour à l'as
poulx connaissait l'origine du mot fan
woods non vous connaissez cette origine
eh bien c'était en 2012 lors expliquer à
nos téléspectateurs des nouveautés
spectateurs sont arrivés depuis peu
qu'est ce que c'est que les fans 12 dans
les phases où c'est les gens qui voient
la garde touche pas à mon poste ont fait
qu il nous suit voilà et qui aime
beaucoup d'émissions et l'expression est
né en 2012 cyril animé allait m'appeler
l'époque l'émission virgin radio france
avec comme invités beth ditto de gossip
et nos raquettes avec lui lui pose une
question en anglais parti et enora cyril
bon animateur la 3d en français et se
dit je vais quand même là reposez moi
aussi on nous les ferons mieux qui
n'aura que non le voyage était de lits
circus c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
est ce que c'est la première fois que
vous remettez le prix afin les dieux de
première phase times 72
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que ça vient de là j'avais
oublié on embrasse tous les fans
toulousains d'ailleurs bien sûr je ne
peux oublier ça et la toile qu'on a
adoré sur d8 c'était le jeu d'aventuré
mais il m'est plus expresses que pékin
pourrait traverser parce qu'elle
comptait 8 au tout début je vous raconte
je voulais faire les malins ils sont dix
ont balancé des grands jeux d'aventuré
et voilà et puis ça a pas fléchir comme
on dit une sortie de route
pourtant il avait casté meilleure
candidate du monde notamment hadji et
yacine rappeler vos deux meilleurs amis
ils sont interviewés et un des deux sur
une belle expression vraiment une
expression pas simple à son pote qui est
tellement surpris il n'arrive pas à
cacher son admiration rappelez vous
savez pas trop quoi parce que ça faisait
deux fois qu'on est avant dernier donc
là on avait vraiment ce dp damoclès
sur nos têtes c'est aussi les gars qui
font les danses les plus bizarres quand
un gars leur donne un indice dans direct
justice 5
merci mec
[Applaudissements]
graff et nous
pourrais je te ramène l a dit pas mal la
coiffure la loro de koh lanta réfléchir
on va continuer à travailler car il va
avoir des cadeaux pour vous toute la
soirée sur twitter on lance tout de
suite racheta de cadeaux voilà on vous
appellera il ya des cadeaux qui vont
tomber pour vous il y aura des cadeaux
pour le public je vous le dis et pour
monsieur
il y aura bien sûr de la pression points
[Applaudissements]
travaille fort il ya un scooter a gagné
ce soir un hashtag cadeau à scooter qui
part ce soir il ya des xbox a gagné et
vous allez voir il ya des trucs de fou
des trucs de fou et vous vous ouais vous
allez voir alors j'ai vu des gens vont
regarder et ça vaut regarder à une année
au formulaire colle pas trop
[Applaudissements]
oui d'accord alors il ne sait pas où ils
veulent pas trop mais vous inquiétez pas
il va faire là soir il va faire la fête
toute la nuit et vallées par tout ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que c'est pas
pourquoi parce que on l'a peu vu dans le
car il ya des animaux avec lui ah bon
non il ya des ânes ya des cherry and an
et vous allez voir je sais pourquoi moi
je sens que pour faire la fête
le meilleur endroit ça reste quand même
chez un des chroniqueurs n'ont plus de
l'ancien nom qu'on a les clés de la
maison blindant trouve nay
et qui va les faire là et qu'ils
allaient faire la fête
il va aller faire la fête là bas vous
verrez avec toute cette petite équipe
voilà donc je pense que ça va lui plaire
voilà haut niveau continue à être votre
ami chez qui c'est qui vont aller vous
pouvez gagner xboxiens chez le
chroniqueur que vous pensez hashtag chez
le chroniqueur et on vous appellera pour
gagner il ya combien 8 x box à lui moi
je mets un petit hashtag delormeau
[Applaudissements]
dollars mots c'est pas lui
mais j'aime bien barrés vous dit tout
mais je pense que quand vous allez voir
ce qu'on vous a préparé vous à dire vous
auriez mieux fait d'aller chez moi allez
c'est bon on parlait de masi right on a
vu déjà deux candidats
on avait adoré cette émission et nous
avait aussi offert grâce à leur candidat
le tchèque le plus raté de l'histoire
deux des huit rappelez vous
[Applaudissements]
puis surtout pour traverser le monde il
avait vraiment choisi les candidats les
plus bilingues
histoire de faciliter les choses on
s'est quand même bien et c'est non rose
moyal avec hathaway ces notions demandé
disparu n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
il y avait michael jackson il y avait
comment s'appelle sylvain stallone après
il y avait marie cuite marais ce truc
c'est ça elodie ct
c'est stallone nombre tu veux le
stallone c'est mon idole les fans mais
bon je suis le bon bilan là il en a même
dans les lunettes mon chéri ça va vous
êtes la crème
ouais j'avais par tous et dégouline
certains nourrissent lui laissa comment
s'attaquer l'intérieur des cuisses
j'ai pas de la crème vous allez c'est
pas bon c'est bien marrer sur des 8 puis
le drame un certain 16 octobre 2014
l'histoire se déroule à nous je compte
sur marne alors que le petit cyril se
promener tranquillement sur la route du
succès il fait percuter de plein fouet
par the cover alors poursuit qu'il peut
l'être émission on a rappelé que c'était
un ch'ti nation c'est un télé crochet
une émission qui devrait compenser le
candidat qui ferait la meilleure reprise
ça s'est pas déroulé comme prévu dès le
début de l'émission on sentait que
c'était sur une autre chaîne
c'est vrai d'ailleurs je vous le dis on
fêtera l'anniversaire de the cover au
cimetière du père lachaise le 16 octobre
proche
voilà je vous le dis non mais je vous le
dis merci de respecter notre peine j'ai
demandé aux gens de ne pas applaudir
pendant ces images cvo siens et de
respect dont il était dedans
moi je comprends pourquoi aussi le
dessin avait le pauvre vieille blake n y
comprennent même pas ce qu'ils faisaient
à rien le graët s'est dit j'étais sur ma
route ils m'ont appelé alors aulas les
fêtes
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est extrait
parce que déjà série dès le début on
s'est dit wa lâ ilâha fonds éperon the
cover du tout tout ce que je voulais et
eh bien on va voir mais tout ce qu'il
voulait en fait c'était sur une autre
chaîne et montré qu'il pouvait le faire
regardez vous vous sentez belinda tokyo
klaus est parti pendant trois minutes
c'est lé troisième finaliste les
meilleurs mais je vous rassure il s'est
ressaisi c'est un professionnel monsieur
hanouna aps une erreur on verra le
premier finaliste jérôme revon qui est
le premier finaliste 2 au vote
[Applaudissements]
gevor est la cover the boys l'importante
couverture jusque là pour la voir seule
la voix compte
là bas c'est tu sois la couverture on
peut dire ce qu on plaisante un peu mais
cyril c'est un animateur hyper rassurant
et ça ça fait plaisir parce que comme
dans tout les télé crochets dont the
cover il ya des candidats éliminés c'est
le principe du jeu
dans cet extrait on est aux portes de la
finale des candidats arrête complètement
leurs prestations en demi finale et
cyril c'est ça qu'on aime chez lui il a
les mots justes pour les rassurer les
encourager il leur fait comprendre que
rien n'est perdu ils vont peut-être
quand même arriver à la finale c'est ça
qui est beau
[Musique]
cardinaux viennent
ils nous ont reprise du black eyed peas
merci merci à vous ça va ça va ça va et
bah bravo en tout cas vous et bon retour
sur lignon
[Applaudissements]
les enfants y compris tous partent un
petit peu en vrille dans cette émission
ce cover on s'est dit que l'émission
retrouverez du sérieux comme dans toutes
les émissions il ya un moment sérieux
ces deux moments solennels de l'arrivée
de l'huissier
mais non même lui ça n'a pas fait ça
voulait pas ça voulait pas on sent un
cyril sur les aboient je me rappelle
d'un non je loupe ma vie c'est ça qui a
gagné qui a fait la meilleure version ce
soir je vais demander à notre huissier
bertrand truttmann ne s'appelle vraiment
bertrand truc mal lu c'est aurillac a
loupé ça arrive c'est vraiment une lisse
arrivera jamais ça arrive que chez nous
[Applaudissements]
mais là j'ai rapporté aux
téléspectateurs à écouter déjà sur au
bout du rouleau de cette émission est ce
qu'elle est en direct et et là je lis et
là on me dit dans l'oreille
comment il s'appelle j truc manon
m'arriver je déconnais ici s'appelle
truc mansion vcc c'est vous c'est fou je
vais voir comment les jo je suis sortie
de l'émission on était avec le bain des
patrons de la chaîne franck à pied tous
et il ya une jeune fille qui était qui
assistent à l'émission qui m'a fait
comme ça vu comme ça me fait pleurer
parce qu'un vague mais pourquoi tu l'as
fait c'est bien sûr je vous jure que
c'est vrai et depuis elle s'en est pas
remis sa décision et sauriez depuis tous
les jours elle regarde voilà slam pour
se remettre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y avait géré a aussi dans l'émission
vous demande en régie s'ils peuvent me
retrouver l'image c'était parti pour la
quotidienne à la base mais en attendant
il ya quand même une autre émission qui
a cartonné sur des beats et les 60 ans
d'europe 1 à lille et par qui c'est
encore pour sa pomme j'ai reçu les amis
à lui toujours sympa notamment le
chanteur raphaël qui lui faisait plein
de compliments lui aussi de vraies
belles retrouvailles quoi lui gentiment
vous êtes sympa vous êtes auto valley et
là raphaël bas confirme la vanne en fait
merci sommes merci merci merci
d'exercice à coutances amara très
content de te voir raphaël fait
tellement longtemps chaque année tous
les angles mais toi tu n'as pas changé
non plus aussi si moi je suis devenu
dégueulasse tout est encore plus beau
qu'avant c'est vrai puisqu'il a
longtemps il m'a regardé fait non mais
c'est votre période chanteur au niveau
du dos le look je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé avant cette émission c'est lg vous
lire j'ai pris ce qui m'est tombé là
sous la main dans la loge chez saint
maclou que je mettais je m'étais fait
faire caca dessus par un pigeon la juste
avant l'arrêt merci et jade ans et qui
anime les concerts parce que voilà
vraiment c'est un gars il plaisante
souvent tpb pendant les concerts le gard
et focus le gars est concentré il a
beaucoup bossé l'ado des invités
notamment quand il lance un des titres
les plus vendus de l'année dit le duo
entre calogero et 400 crise regard des
achats d'or encore plein d'autres
artistes qui vont arriver
pour le moment c calogero et les 400
suis c'est parti
et après rendant c'est le duo après
trois minutes de live vous êtes le seul
animal docile il a pourtant posé cette
question à laquelle ogero la réponse est
directe et vous pensez que c'est
possible qu'un jour vous fassiez un
titre ensemble ou pas bailly les faits
[Applaudissements]
là on vient de on a fait la cua cyril
cdpa ya deux heures c'était cité la
série l'ont bien voilà on est venu pour
ça on est reparti quoi l'on fait ouais
c'est ça tu m'uses à l'autre mais c'est
toi qui a dit qu'on entend ça c'est pas
mieux cyril j'ai presque d'entrée
l'image de gérard l'image de gérard non
mais bien parce la pensée si c'est une
des pages de dire on va la retrouver
maintenant je suis en train de chercher
à mon avis aïe non ils ont ils ont une
palette de cover gérard est invité et
c'est vrai que quand on pense comme sa
nouvelle émission série n'avait eu du
pif il a il a invité le gars le plus web
de l'équipe
le mec tendance gérard louvin cas kezman
iphone 3g moment ce we may have et
gérard et à cette fois qu'on lui dit
qu'il est là qu'il fait toujours mal
quand même y avait ma manche les bears
mais on s'est bien fait piéger voilà
mais pas de moi je me suis beaucoup
amusé c'était pas très bien photo ja
balaye mais isabelle adjahi bah ouais
vous referai la prochaine avec moi ah
mais moi oui d'ailleurs vous ne m'aviez
réquisitionné j'étais en cours de route
mais j'ai pas regretter moi j'ai
beaucoup ri moi du moment que je ris que
je danse samba
jalel mélanie la future ville alors
allez vous gérer
c'est pourquoi il était sur le plateau
parce qu'il connaît les dernières
tendances musicales
il est dans le coup j'ai dans le vent
regard des géants dans un instant vous
allez nous présenter un orchestre
exceptionnel
oui c'est un orchestre que j'ai
découvert cet orchestre symphonique qui
jouent tous les succès de maintenance et
ailleurs et ça va des beatles à carson
jackson à habas et tout ça en symphonie
lyrique dans une autre époque et vous
même eu une vie dans notre circuit quand
même dire que leur caisse est jamais
passé
je vais vous dire c'est sur le générique
est le plus de monde si à côté de moi
qui attendait pour chanter là j'avais
chanté sauté après chez lui il y avait
des grands artistes et mister caniche ah
ouais on se calme bonjour merci celle de
ses trois années de bonheur qui nous a
offert en skeet juste avec une dernière
image l'anecdote de cyril qui a le plus
marqué ses trois ans deux des huit merci
à lui
ça a l'air d'avoir plus en tout cas
votre prestation
moi je me rappelle juste un truc c'est
qu'elle a fait très très attention parce
que à la répète elle a failli tomber là
quand elle s'est assise là ça allait
mieux
[Musique]
et pourtant dû servir à tester un clou
parce que si ce concert vous remercier
pour ces trois ans et parce qu'on a eu
un des plus grands fous rires de toutes
les deux de tout ces trois ans sur des
mythes c'était sur un enfant de star
bruce a appris que gilles et isabelle
avait faute et qu'il avait eu un enfant
voulait avoir son image voulez vouloir
montrer et là je suis carrément passer
sous la table
regardez ça isabelle aurait fait une
danse endiablée agile et apparemment ils
ont commis l'irréparable on a retrouvé
la photo de leur fille on l'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la paix quel côté il y en ait plus
désobligeants
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est malheureux mais c'est elle et pas
du tout l est pas français je suis
décidé de la faire venir dont là je la
connais pas j'ai pratiqué
merci
entre elles
jade les vents d est parti dans un vade
les parties avec des animaux avec la
compagnie créole avec reda regarder
voilà tout ce qu'il ya dedans il est au
bout du rouleau à vos claviers il sera
chézard des chroniqueurs dans un instant
il a les clés va aller faire la fête là
bas vous verrez ça pour le moment on va
revenir sur les images marquantes un
bien sûr de ses trois ans deux des huit
et je crois que thierry moreau dont vous
avez quelque chose d'une image qui vous
a marqué le palmashow ne pas taxer aussi
rexel à la parodie c'est tellement
compliqué que les gens qui arrivent à le
faire il ya des gens qui il ya eu les
nuls il n'égale pas le macho avec la
folle soirée du palmashow et il ya un
sketch moi qui m'a absolument marque
fait marrer c'est la parodie qu'ils ont
fait the voice qui en plus est
d'actualité parce que comme garou
revient la tâche de jennyfer ça tombe
bien ses poils d'actu volant c'est à
mourir de rire
regardez cache un homme de talent un
calice et dans le jury va falloir qu'on
soit sobre et très concentré dans un
univers tu peux est un bois quelle
prestance hier que google ou yahoo
moi je suis la petite nouveau monsieur
tellement fiable dans le jury de the
voice je compte rester humble d'un hiver
mais tu es nul je vais t'expliquer en
quatre chapitres et 18 sous partie
pourquoi tu ne peux pas être le voit et
on dit la voix pas le voit il est con ce
libanais cette année y'a plein d'univers
il ya beaucoup de talents qui moi je la
mettrais plaindre robe avec très peu
tissu tu as vraiment
interpellé dans cette émission parce que
tu m'as tu m'a touché tu as vraiment un
univers à toi mais en fait moi je suis
technicien changé au micro voilà c'est
ça que j'aime taton libératoire moi je
te veux je te veux dans mon équipe
lise ben oui d'accord
excellent sur des attentions le patron
céder à des chroniqueurs et qu'on en
fasse la surprise à matthieu delormeau
prévoir gt président ben ali les parties
du plateau c'est fou ce qu'on va lui
faire aujourd'hui je pense qu'il va s'en
souvenir un mathieu mais bon on l aime
beaucoup vos si vous allez faire un
petit truc guînes à vous êtes le plus
courageux d'entre nous ben non vous
allez trouver encore gérard ya une image
qui vous a marqué c'est quoi
bah moi c'est une c'est dans l'émission
à vos régions oui c'est le fion degré de
s'occuper de son chien comment on fait
un pion bah oui je rigolais mais c'est
une spécialité de pâtisserie où on met
la main avec des flancs c'est un flan
aux oeufs et tout ça ayez moi qui était
pâtissier je me suis beaucoup intéressée
au fion de son garçon
regardez regardez c'est c'était l'option
on va faire un fiancé la maison ça c'est
normal ça n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on
peut imaginer bien évidemment si on veut
dire flanc en patois vendéen s'est
toujours traditionnel il ya toujours de
la cannelle
pendant les essais dans le fion non non
le truc c'est que quand on se met à
faire des choix il faut il faut éviter
les copains quoi parce que derrière faut
les manger chez nous c'est vraiment pas
un problème faut de la place pour faire
un film
il veut de l'appelant il faut la place
vraiment casser la croûte du chien nous
allons peut être dit en champion
[Applaudissements]
demain soir
direct auto grégory jade actuellement
dans les pionts claque à nice et dans
les filles vous savez que vous êtes ce
que vous avez une info sur les fillon
oui parce qu'il faut mettre les mains
dedans
non mais sans rigoler dans la recette
est ce que sa dernière virginie fiom et
oui j'ai mangé du chien le problème mais
je me veux tu dois savoir thé bretonne
ça veut dire flanc fait pas l'injection
breton mais ces nations et non merci on
coupera sa non pas les toits des halles
et au on va se faire un petit kiff en
regardant les premières fois de touche
pas à mon poste tout de suite c'est
touche pas à mes premières c'est parti
du leader
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et arrêtons de la table est-ce que nous
retrouver ce que vous souvenez de votre
première fois dans l'émission sur d8 qui
étaient là qui étaient là lors de la
première première stuff carrière thierry
moreau jean michel maire était là gérard
compas vous étiez là sur la première l'a
promis de démissionner de dijon met dos
des huit lots intégré vous y étiez et
bertrand chamerois aussi était là on
s'en rappelle on avait gad elmaleh il
est tout à coup le studio avec nous le
jour de la première
et comme d'habitude ils avaient mis le
feu regardez c'était du grand gad attiré
la toute l'équipe j'étais venu habillé
comme ça pour honorer cette première et
pour que ça vous porte bonheur
tu as remarqué quand tu lances un
extrait ya toujours un petit temps ça
arrive pas alors je vais te dire
pourquoi il ya des personnes en régie
qui sont là en emploi précaire il à dire
m
tu vois pas pourquoi on n'a plus de
valeur
c'est exactement ça
[Applaudissements]
c'était la première première de des
luttes car première donc 2 sur des buts
ne savais pas du tout où on allait
thierry moreau annonce c'est sûr ça
avait fait cinq cent mille
téléspectateurs ce qui était déjà plutôt
bien
oui et surtout on savait pas que ça
deviendra ce point là voilà j'en ai
surtout et c'est vous et la c3 dans des
8es des huit voilà ce se porte très bien
en tout cas alors il ya eu en trois ans
8746 licenciement de mecs en régie les
embrasser bien sûr on les aime
il ya d'autres choses qui va arriver
bien sûr sur les premières fois c'était
le 20 mai c'était le jour de la
naissance de balzac et de l'indépendance
bien sûr du timor oriental et c'était la
première participation d'isabelle
morini-bosc dans tp on s'en souvient et
isabelle on a tout de suite senti son
potentiel son professionnalisme à
isabelle morini bosc
vous allez voir première émission et
premier tu sors pour isa c'était le 20
mai 2013 regarde puis on va reparler de
l'eurovision tout de suite isabelle
morini bosc qui lève le doigt parce que
là alors nous visionnons ça n'a pas très
bien marché
samedi soir sur france 3 on va faire un
petit point sur les audiences
oui j'aimerais bien faire un petit point
sur les ventes et j'aimerais vous c'est
votre première j'espère que je sois pas
votre dernier c'était bocaly mois donc
des fleurs en octobre j'aimerais bien ok
beaucoup reproché à julien qu'on met
deux tweeté ces derniers temps
j'aimerais bien revenir sur un tweet
qu'il a fait là sur l'eurovision et que
je trouve très bien en revanche il a
tweeté willa julian tu as tout et nous
contrairement à noyer les tweets les
atouts t elle une amie ni té qu'est-ce
qu'il a tout est dit le parce qu'on le
voit l'antenne indique le alors il a
trouvé le fond me dire prendre cette
tournée ça va excusez moi sortez sortez
sortez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tenez afin d'éviter mettez vous la
sortez de votre collègue de chez darty
la classe n3 darty ici
[Applaudissements]
l automne
ça va mieux depuis
j'étais pas plus vieille qu'aujourd'hui
noie pas non bourrage unissez vous
rajeunissez vous êtes à côté du champion
du tu l'as vu un pour appeler la
jeunesse du tu l'as vu c'était grâce à
bertrand tu ont montré pourquoi on a
fait des tu l'as vu la cité l'étude a vu
mon cul bien sûr avec bertrand et c'est
grâce à vous allez voir d'où ces partis
tu l'as vu mon cul on aura le premier tu
l'as vu un de gérard louvin un triomphe
et dans un instant on retrouvera xavier
gandon le patron de des huit qui sera
chez un des chroniqueurs il va rentrer
avec la compagnie créole avec des
animaux il va faire la fête vous allez
voir il y aura des cadeaux à chaque
cadeau tout de suite les chéris parce
que vous allez voir ce qu'on va faire il
y aura des cadeaux de fou pour tout le
monde ya un scooter a gagné il ya des
reebok des baskets il ya des ips bottes
voilà il ya plein de choses à tout de
suite petite beauté sur des mythes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les huit pour les trois ans de la
chaîne 3 ans que des huit merci à tous
d'être là vers signer chez rip gerdemann
et qui hélas beaucoup d'entre vous c'est
donc à l'instant elle va nous faire
gagner un scooter pour vous c'est
bouillant un scooter allez-y donc
acheter un cadeau on appellera quelqu'un
je vous le dis tout de suite et qui
partira avec le scooter pendant une
séquence
il n'y aura également pour vous 8 xbox
xbox gamer il y aura pour vous des
cadeaux dieu de leur mort un cadeau dans
un instant on va retrouver le patron de
d'éviter xavier gandon qui sera devant
la porte de l'un des chroniqueurs avec
des animaux avec la compagnie créole
avec des danseurs avec je ne sais pas
quoi
avec tout et il fera la fête chez un des
chroniqueurs ils ne savent pas des
tissages et même eux ne savent pas donc
hashtag le nom du chroniqueur je vous le
dis voilà pour gagner même pas pour
gagner une xbox voilà ça sympa et bien
sûr il y aura beaucoup de cadeaux pour
ceux qui nous soutiennent tous les jours
aussi non seulement les gens chez eux
mais également le public et il y a
premier cadeau on va vous distribuez
avant que vous ne partiez chacun eh bien
il ya pour chacun je crois qu'il ya
quarante barres chocolatées
[Applaudissements]
dix jours après vous reporter
et pendant ce temps d'une chanson
c'est moi le seul samassa vent selon
l'association il ya plus il a tout de
4000 quelque chose de brno
voilà vous avez tous compris voilà on va
distribuer là y compris merci
on va décider les démarches gouéno voilà
comme c'est comme celle usage a bien
entendu bien des grandes on sera prêt et
sera chez l'un d'eux des chroniqueurs
dans un instant juste avant on voulait
vous montrer parce que dans les trois
ans deux des huit s'est passé quelque
chose aussi s'est-elle tu l'as vu tu
l'as vu gérard louvin alors on a vu des
tuiles a vu la dernière fois mais là la
jeunesse du tu l'as vu c'est bertrand
chaverot hésité dans une de vos
chroniques est ce que vous rappelez
alors je les crois que c'était on avait
redoublé une conférence de didier
deschamps
exactement exactement regardez comment
c'est apparu ce qui donne pendant les
conférences belote dix minutes plus tard
attention 3d est un peu là poilades si
bien plaît c'est un classique souhaité
passer des heures entières en classe
affaires savoir je vous mets au défi au
moment de placer un tube à vue alors
qu'à vous place tu l'as vu qu'ils m'ont
[Applaudissements]
il y en a
il n'aura qu'un rôle dès le premier des
puits où tu l'as vu vous le savez
julienc a relevé premier défi du tu l'as
vu moi j'ai enlevé à dire c'est bien
c'est le roi du tulle est d'ailleurs
maintenant on a oublié qu'il a fait du
cinéma
maintenant pour tous les français c'est
le roi du tulle et qu'elle invitait
timsit ce quoi patrick timsit très bien
et j'aime souvient de sa tête
areva vous allez revoir sa tête les
images regardez c'est pas c'est pas
facile de passer de chanteur et comédien
il joue très très bien parce qu'il ya
une super ambiance légeret savoir est-ce
que tu l'as vu le film est-ce que je les
ai vus quoi pardon mon cul
[Applaudissements]
et
toujours à tout seul
car dsk des gens dans la rue qui vous
disent est ce que tu l'as vu des tueries
gold c'est trois fois par jour non ah
non mais je rigole pas et alors vous
l'avez j'existe pub autrement non c'est
non alors tu l'as vu une autre fois dans
le train tu l'as vu j'arrive à allouagne
et ouais tu l'as vu
on sent même au maroc ça lui arrive
j'ai toujours que tu l'as vu mais il y
en marre au coeur d'une ville
mais ce qui m'épate c'est que au maroc
qui regarde beaucoup des huit ans dans
la rue place jamais fait à marrakech
alors et où la vue à chamonix
alors les premières fois c'est toujours
délicat et je vous le dis là ça y est
ils sont arrivés chez le chroniqueur un
senior ils sont devant la porte
vous demandez-vous nour des touches et
qu'il est agréable et d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je vous le dis
j'aimerais passer je pense
voilà comme comme jeu au pied tous les
chroniqueurs en tout cas de camille va
rentrer aussi ce que camille veut
participer vous devez vois pas ce que je
vais dire de qui il s'agit et chez
quelques chroniqueurs ils sont dans un
instant chlamydia abadie avocat me vient
aussi t'asseoir parce que je veux tu
réagisses thomas blatt su
[Musique]
on va regarder d'abord avant de voir
shekels chroniqueur à des gants dont le
patron est allé avec des animaux il va
faire la fête toute la soirée là bas
folie il est là par là et à côté vous
crois que je suis un taxi chroniqueur
veut remettre un chroniqueur d'abord
pour vraiment bien casser l'ambiance on
va voir la première vague de thierry
moreau sur des buts est ce que vous vous
rappelez de votre première vannes
pas du tout c'était une blague bien
pourri qui rit comme d'habitude ouais
c'est collector regarder la première
vannes de thierry moreau il était déjà
lourd
il ya trois ans 18 minutes
c'est un bon rythme c'est ça ouais c'est
ça thierry ça marche bien ça mais ça
marche pas mal quand il dit ça c'est
qu'il venait tous les jours je vais bien
j'ai c'est un escroc
ça fait un carton chez les cul-de-jatte
à montfermeil il était en fête
[Musique]
il est bon la première vous êtes malade
vous laisse encore une chance sinon vous
sort l'oubli et jerry a relevé un clip
haut niveau après quelques vannes plus
tard s'est notamment illustré dans
l'émission du 11 mars 2014 avec une
vanne exceptionnel est-ce que vous
rappeler ce qui s'est passé à 11 mars
gérard loi qui s'est passé à 11 mars
11 mars en général papa dans cette
émission j'ai rencontré ma femme journée
la femme celui des miss
merci là toujours qu'au jour de retard
était alors 11 mars normalement 11 mars
la saint valentin non non 11 max r non
ouais mais alors le 11 mars tous les ans
c'est l'anniversaire de dave nom de la
mort d'un show de repenser 3 donc je
prends soin au 18 juillet c'est en
novembre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça s'active déjà banni re serré et donc
la joie
d'ailleurs vous avez une histoire à
chaque fois sur claude françois il avait
envoyé au courant avant alors quand et
4000 fans et j'adore ah oui non il ya là
comme en espagne ça l'astrologue qui
faisait l'astrologie
l'astrologue de podium qui que je voyais
mois de temps en temps ouais et claude
me dit tu la vois les biens qu'il veut
et j'ai dit oui et il me dit j'aimerais
bien que quelqu'un fasse mon thème et il
me donne sa vraie date de naissance
parce qu'il est riche et un petit peu et
je donne sa date de naissance à cette
femme et j'avais quinze jours après je
vais la voir et elle nous dit mais ce
qu'il a des problèmes d'argent et ce
qu'il a des problèmes je le vois se voit
disparaître
aïe comment tu vois vous voyez comment
vous le voyez 10 à 10 chez pas et c'est
en suisse ça a un rapport avec l'eau
donc je pense qu'il a fuie en suisse je
pense qu'il est parti en suisse fausse
j'arrive gmail yassa sur la cassette
thème dit oui le claude écoute le truc
il descend dans mon bureau il me dit
akon là c'est bien il prend son
assurance vie l'air de rien et il meurt
quelques temps après en revenant de
genève comme on le sait tous les pieds
les gays non mais c'est assez incroyable
c'est fou ça j'avais quand même si en
fait je voulais un truc pour vous
remettre un petit peu d'ambiance dans
ses vêtements
enfin des anniversaires et c'est tout ça
c'est toujours un succès et bien la mort
de cloclo et bien
c'était
yingli à une blague il ya une blague de
thierry moreau là dessus regarde pas bon
je crois qu'ils eurent de l'affairé
parlé d'un truc avant que ça continue
qu'est-ce qui se passe non rien non mais
oui et non mais c'est une jour d'un
anniversaire aujourd'hui quoi c'est quoi
11 mars
oui claude françois oui 1978 on était au
courant assez anniversaire non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sommaire
trois ans après au même endroit ce truc
il réagira dépend courant oui j'ai fait
la même blague à illenoo route
excusez moi juste si vous nous rejoignez
sur des vitres et des trois ans je dis
vite c'est moi il ya groland cap et il
faut retourner la terre j'ai regardé
c'est le passé le préciser que ses
impôts il ya ourthe coiffer les yaourts
ça lui va très bien comme ça bravo bravo
jugé le gab déconner je déconne
justement on va passer à la croix la
poitrine verdez avant de découvrir ce
qu'est le chroniqueur nous sommes allés
c'est là ils sont arrivés là il arrive
dans deux minutes je sais pas qui c'est
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est que ces
riches l'arema saison et valérie vidal
et ou de leurs mots n'ont apparemment
valérie ou de leurs mots ont juré la
mort il n'a pas séché le toit maintenant
il n'a pas complètement tort joaillier
ça va
il n'y a pas tant chez vous non y'a
personne à la maison il est brun
peut-être quelqu'un à nom mario qua non
pour moi c'est pour arranger
non mais il a décelé petite reine nov il
ya des strings qui traînent on est allés
chez mathieu renault
[Applaudissements]
boughazi le vau l'eau dit ça n'est pas
mathieu delormeau avant de voir chez qui
on va à moi si elle n'est pas mathieu
delormeau m'a dit c'est pas valérie je
peux pas dire ça ne peut pas dire ça
vous souvenez notre première fois dans
touche pas à mon poste
j'étais déguisé au début j'étais né vous
êtes tout on regarde alors tous ceux qui
aiment le football le connaissent j'ai
dit à mes potes ce week-end que je
faisais rentrée ce garçon dans la bande
et tulio la la c'est le procureur le
procureur ici on vous appellera pas le
procureur a bien ouais vous appellera
gilles vous appellera pas d'ailleurs
c'est gilles verdez gardel sais pas ce
que vous en pensez
ça fait très mec qui se présente aux
municipales bonjour voter vers des
beautés verdès vous serez plus à l'aise
au niveau coiffure on va faire quoi
pendant cette année j'ai à disposition
au rsa comme ça quelque chose on va
essayer on va rester comme ça pour le
moment on prend des listes mais on aime
bien
[Musique]
vous ne trouvez pas ouais cc puis je
vous écoute beaucoup vos conseils m'ont
aidée aussi
jls aujourd'hui on fait pas que les
trois individus sont aussi
l'anniversaire de votre tout premier
j'ai mal à ma france à lens en rappel
c'est dans tpm pc il ya deux ans pile
c'était le 8 octobre 2013 que vous avez
sorti le premier j'ai mal à ma france et
y est très très remonté contre la télé
réalité de m6 retour au pensionnat à la
campagne regardez gilles verdez en
pensez-quoi telle émission
je suis très meurtrie par cette émission
j'aimerais mais vrd vous avez vu on met
le gars ça veut dire qu'il était chez
lui hier ça il faut toucher meurtre et
1to pause par les deux minutes côté
salon stopper ou pas son salon je suis
meurtri parle poursuit je trouve
extrêmement problématique que le modèle
éducatif qu'on essaye de donner à nos
enfants soit celui d'une france
coloniale maintenant je vois ça
franchement j'ai mal à ma france
mais ce qu'il advient mais je n'imagine
d'hier soir vous l'uriné dans ce lieu et
coups de feu touché balle à bâle iii
il avait des hommes à lhassa france un
bon ou un mauvais rêve mais est ce que
vous préparez les choses les des trucs
l'ailé les punchlines s'avoue bien comme
ça je me promène beaucoup je marche
marche rapide et j'essaie de trouver des
trucs rapide m'aide à réfléchir
[Rires]
voilà ça y est tata et tonton sont
encadrés sont très contents dans un
instant je vous le dis on ira chez un
des chroniqueurs mais il n'y aura pas
que ça il y a il y en a un qui aime
particulièrement
un objet qui lui appartient vraiment il
est fou de cet objet il est fou voilà 2
2 ce qui lui permet de venir tous les
jours à des huit c'est bien sûr sa
voiture
[Musique]
tranquille
j'aurais juste vous montrer quelque
chose c'est une vidéo qu'on a trouvé ça
n'a rien à voir ce qui va se passer ici
les regarde au [ __ ] c'est qu'est ce
que c'est que ça alors là c'est une
dépanneuse est ce que quelqu'un recoller
sa voiture de marque
moi c'est ça qu'est keynes marque
blanche comme ça oui il ya une aura oui
oui c'est bon et à qui d'autre des temps
si on accuse yake laura ou alors ça doit
que la voiture des doigts quoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya mais les banques soutiennent
oui et vous pareil mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non on peut par voie d'accord
l'avion blanche et noire
alors les champs toujours pu risquer au
fait qu'est-ce qui l'a alors sa venue
parce que j'ai deux passions
oui les montres et les voitures ah ouais
et plus votre voiture
bah oui fao et la danse aussi un mois
mais je sais je sais mais ça m'étonne
telle histoire parce qu'aujourd'hui suis
tombé en panne avec les way et donc
voilà les chais marche plus donc allé
chez
je sais monde est allé la chercher
hommage adore les grands malades
[Applaudissements]
oui désolé monchal a annoncé l'armée
c'est peut-être pas celle de mathieu
arrête en chercher une juste la voiture
qu'on est allé chercher à l'intérieur
rouge en haut mais rate un nom mais
c'est ainsi une option que j'écris
[Musique]
je vous jure c'est vrai ça n'existe pas
avec escales le cuir rouge fait
l'histoire vraie du coup je vous jure
que c'est vrai c'est un cuir à part que
j'ai fait poser shehzad bref vous jure
coûté 3 tonnes moi je propose tout de
suite sa cure qu'on fasse on fasse qu'on
fasse la séquence du monster truck
[Applaudissements]
écouter avant de voir ces quelques
chroniqueurs on est là et c'est pour ça
que je dis c'est pas mathieu mathieu
vous allez avoir dans un instant des
nouvelles de votre voiture
mathieu je vais vous poser 5
questionnant mirande laquelle vous vous
allez pouvoir la sauver
j'allais pouvoir la sauver toute façon
elles marchent plus qu'ils nous
emmerdent de la batterie attention c'est
des questions c'est des questions sur
touche pas à mon poste
d'accord j'ai posé cinq questions sur ce
qui s'est passé pendant ces trois ans
est ce qu'on peut voir s'il vous plaît
ce qu'on peut avoir une image
faites un plan fait un plan sur l'autre
d'abord allé à lessines fait imploré
d'uddevalla la même s'il restait là tu
es sage mais là-dessus rester là dessus
s'ils veulent d'abord steven à ce que
vous pouvez montrer ce que vous savez
faire un matthieu delormeau simone
là alors ça
ça c'était une voiture qui est à la
casse mathieu je vais tout faire pour
que vous sauviez votre voiture
je vous aime mathieu et bien sûr le pas
de ceux-là mais elle à la vitre noir
damien alary vitres noires aussi comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
g
moi je fais la même chose est claire je
pensais c'est ta voiture merci alors
mathieu voici la première question tu te
plait je fais une danse ne l'est jamais
james hogan
alors si vous la sauvez vous faites une
danse ah ben oui si je la sens j'ai ce
que tu veux mais non mathieu voici la
première question le 4 décembre 2013
dans touche pas à mon poste on se bat
plaque annoncées vont arrêter de montrer
la voiture de voiture arrêtée saoule
arrêtez arrêtez de la montée ça le fou
le bourdon alors par mathieu mathieu à
chaque fois que vous répondrez mal
steven avancera d'un mètre si vous
faites trois erreurs
il avancera jusqu'à la voiture et steven
est inarrêtable
mathieu voici la question
le 4 décembre 2013 dans tpm p une vraie
info sur gérard louvin est tombé
laquelle il a fait de la coloc avec
dette dans les années 60 il a une tante
qui s'appelait soeur gérarld où il a été
le premier producteur de t'choupi en
france alors si vous voyez il a fait de
la coloc avec dave dans les années 60
qu'elle subit là une tante qui
s'appelait soeur gérard où il a été le
premier producteur de t'choupi en france
dell c'est un ami donc je connais mon
arrêt parler c'est la 3 il est déjà
monté dans votre voiture die oui
absolument
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est la 3 dont il a été le
premier producteur de t'choupi en france
regardez la réponse en images moi
j'avais une tente ma grand tante qui
s'appellent sorj erhard qui était
dirigée ressort girarde à gérard et en
gérard qui était si ma soeur non mais
vous comment ça pas vous manquer mais
non mais on se moque pas m'excuser et
non pas sur ma soeur était en pension là
bas et quand je dis que j'ai passé deux
mois pendant 6 ans de 12 ans à 18 ans
j'ai j'allais tous les regards des
regards d un petit peu de respect pour
gerrard s'il vous plaît c'est terrible
j'allais tous les quinze jours passé
quinze jours dans l'école dans la robe
est simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raté rapallo téléspectateurs du cian
healy un scooter à gagner dans un
instant on va vous appeler l'un dans
trois cadrans bulletins pour gagner
qu'est-ce qu'il ya mon fou d'avoir un
scooter à trois roues oui mais bon voilà
lui me 10,3 arrêter les voitures étaient
alors je le dis les pays non s'il vous
plaît les chéris c'était bien sûr
surgira dont vous avez perdu
vous nous appellera dans un instant
hashtag cadeau pour gagner ce magnifique
scooter que vous pouvez voir
voilà qui est laquée sur le plateau
attention deuxième question quel
footballeur a provoqué un fou rire sur
ce plateau le 7 février 2013 matières
nobles et d'avancer d'un maître steven
avandamet pour bébé
saft
barrot tue pas
ça c'est bon c'est bon et recul quatre
footballeurs a provoqué un fou rire sur
ce plateau le 7 février 2013 arrêtez dû
montrer sa voiture ça ne dépriment
michel ça pue nicolas sachy ou pire ses
couilles
[Rires]
alors ça allait je sais plus là vous
m'agacer alors attendez même pu gagner
deux là deux donc nicolas sachy basse et
salades horaires non alors ça pue michel
sapin regardons la voiture est ce que ça
chie existe oui ça qui n'en sache i know
you non arrigo sacchi c'est un
entraîneur mais là ça chie il existe c
est des gardiens de but de l'équipe de
sedan et zambie
un jour l'équipe a titré s'agit dans les
vestiges du côté les spectateurs c'est
que j'ai fait tout ce quiz juste pour
cette vente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
mathieu en tout cas pour vous sachiez
pas ça pue
[Rires]
steven avant de remettre mon bébé j'ai
quand même donateur
[Musique]
attendez-vous est là
alors attention les full options et
légendes sport en plus il vous reste
encore trois questions de droit les
coûts sans déconner naturel et j'ai posé
une question la voici
mathieu je sais que vous êtes un grand
littéraire pouvez vous me dire quel a
été le tout premier livre lu dans voyage
au bout de la nuit sur des huit fois ci
c'est mort la poste auch ashton joue les
deux coups voiture je voudrais les trois
propositions
oui oui oui et la gomme magique non le
grand meaulnes un peut-être de gustave
flaubert
je sais je rigole le grand bol j'ai
fourni on est alain fourny exactement
qui avait entraîné le paris saint
germain ou bien le horla de guy deux
appareils en passant guy degrenne ni de
vos passions mathieu là je crois savoir
si vous répondez bien c'est fini
nadal reste encore deux questions ça
passe par contre mes sauts tu peux ce
grand bord de la voiture le grand bol
matthieu delormeau si ça n'est pas le
grand meaulnes
malheureusement steven va avancer si
c'est le grand moule on oublie tout
réponse dans un autre
[Applaudissements]
sur d8 on a des images incroyables à
vous montrer il ya bertrand qui va venir
dormir pour tous les ratés les messieurs
et vous verrez votre première bertrand
ne suis pas sûr d'avoir envie c'est si
vous allez voir c'est pas mal du tout il
ya jean luc lemoine qui va venir nous
rejoindre dès qu'il sort du théâtre il
viendra nous rejoindre direct et je le
dis réjouissez-vous bien maintenant
parce que quand ils varié sera pour les
quatre tiers mais allez voir vous allez
beaucoup rigolé il a dû très très très
très lourd gilles tout à l'heure comme à
chaque prime
bien sûr vous allez relever un défi si
vous êtes le plus courageux d'entre nous
ça c'est super facile si je vous écoute
est-ce que vous croire moi est ce que
vous voulez qu'on non on va la voir dans
un instant je vous montre une photo dans
un instant gym et vous verrez cette
photo va vous parler c'est pas une
personne en fin de vie et pour le moment
on a des choses sur le feu on a bien sûr
sa naïveté on a on a le patron de 2,8
qui est devant la porte d'un des
chroniqueurs sachez que déjà les animaux
sont rentrés c'est ça la compagnie quand
elle est rentrée il y à une fiesta de
fou c'est âgées l'un d'entre vous une
fiesta de malades
vous continuez à tweeté acheter un
cadeau aussi parce que il ya un scooter
a gagné là dans un instant pour le
moment c'est vous matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau
vous avez deux passions dans la vie le
kung fu mais votre voiture
malheureusement vous avez arrêté que
soit l'âge de 6 ans mathieu bon moment
il ya un monster truck un monstre qui ne
pense qu'à une chose c'est cracher votre
voiture que vous aimez
je vous ai posé une question juste avant
la pause mathieu cette question c'est
est est ce que vous pouvez me dire quel
a été le tout premier livre lu dans
voyage au bout de la nuit sur des huit
mâts et dit quoi de grands moulins
fourni oui vous l'avez lu ce livre
oui parler de quoi en tant coûté mathieu
je sais que vous n'êtes pas en état de
me résumer suivre offrait une fiche de
lecture pour lundi le premier livre qui
a été lu dans voyage au bout de la nuit
c'est lors la bonne
il va avancer mais on va lui laisser une
dernière chance on va lui laisser une
dernière chance quoi ça sera la dernière
chance de mathieu d'accord ah bon c'est
steven avancée mais voilà
oh
et d'un jeune fille
avant la dernière question j'aimerais
qu'on appelle une personne qui s'est
inscrite sur twitter et qui va repartir
avec un scooter
allez on appelle tout de suite en direct
avant bien sûr d'opposer la dernière
question à mathieu c'est parti on
appelle je rappelle que on a plus de
facilité à un monster truck ici qu'à
faire un numéro de téléphone
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez touche pas à mon poste des mutas
paradoxe six mois alors la sonnerie et
fortin alors quitte à l'appareil
et ouais ouais et quand ça va c'est
cyril hanouna en étant directement aux
valides ça va elle te plaît l'émission à
whisky walid est ce que tu veux dire un
petit mot à matthieu delormeau
franchement il est bas merde
[Applaudissements]
tu nous as tu t'appelles où tu es où tu
habites lloyd ah ben non
excuse moi qu'est ce que tu veux tu la
manges un robot alors je te regarde
merci oui tu veux nous regardent avec
toute sa famille chez moi avec ma copine
wahou pas les beaux gosses
[Applaudissements]
à quel âge wahid il arrête on est là bas
tant à 20 ans rien est impossible à 20
ans des terrains cible tu fais quoi dans
la demo wahid pack de sport j'adore la
fac j'adore le sport est bien wade je
vais t'expliquer la règle du jeu je vais
poser une dernière question tu peut
éteindre la télé enfin mettent moins
fort au wild t'inquiète pas wahid je
vais t'expliquer la règle du jeu si
matthieu delormeau
sauf sa voiture c'est matthieu delormeau
sauf sa voiture excusez moi il ya des
mecs et savannah écrit là derrière la
lega la non mais où es tu veux pas
fermer ta gueule
non mais le gars est en train de
raconter sa vie qu'il est derrière elle
et qu'on rêverait battue c'est puis le
temps on n'a même pas fait ce constat le
gars est partie à des défis toujours
alors oui mon chéri 6,6 macho de
l'ormeau répond bien on écrase n'a pas
sa voiture et une repartira
malheureusement pas et que ce doute dans
les règles ont été validés par lui si on
peut pas lutter
pas les changer ça a été validée merci
je m'entends là a besoin d'un perroquet
wade si matthieu delormeau se trompe et
qu'il perd sa voiture wahid tu auras
scooter et tu pourras venir chercher
matthieu delormeau d'accord ce matin
attention voici la dernière
la dernière question
je crois que tu as reçu un mail web
[Rires]
[Musique]
attention voici la question est ce qu'on
peut mettre un peu de côté là s'il vous
plaît merci en régie prenait détrôner
des initiatives mais là où sera pas
toujours là bas que vous serez tout seul
attention voici la dernière question est
là je ne serais plus une dernière chance
joli match qui est pour que mathieu
répondent bien qu'ils sont sa voiture
allumette au plateau je veux savoir
julien courbet a le droit à l'erreur ça
serait bien une petite erreur parce que
ça relancerait la soirée bref j'aimerais
bien qu'il garde sa voiture mais pour
voiliers de quand même le footer gilles
moi je suis pour qu'on détruit sa
bagnole
les
jean nuit la voiture
non mais vous avez vu est l'humour de
situation vous le cuir rouge c'est une
faute de goût donc on peut écraser
mais des coûts découvre un peu les
transports en commun je te jure c'est
bien aussi
mon girard toujours soigné le
téléspectateur donc lui donner un
conseil pendant la pupille matin apple
julien combes et elle est toujours très
pro vélo c'est bon tu sais moi j'aime à
10h pour la guerre
j'ai roulé là-bas singer pas la peine
j'ai pas besoin qui me ramène celui ci
tu sais j'ai ma vie mes transports en
commun j'ai mon ticket de métro c'est
laura maintenant l'essentiel c'est quoi
il est un cadeau pardonne-moi parfaite à
plein d'oseille qui va tracer une
voiture arrêtée là quel support est à
walid et surtout ça fera une très belle
séquence camille cas mais j'aime le jeu
jallet sera couverte un donc simplement
si connaissez mieux des huit il aurait
sauvé sa voiture
attention matthieu delormeau
la voici la question c'est quel est le
surnom donné par olivier minne au père
fouras et et la voilà mais non mais s'il
vous plaît c'est important ah oui vous
avez deux secondes 3 s'il n'y a pas
trois positions non mais non pas tant
qu'opposition alors trois secondes
mais ce qui est terrible c'est dans une
autre émission de télé j'ai apprécié
pour une vanne mais vous vous êtes
tellement tard est tellement je fous là
le père fou mais comment vais je le
devine le père fouras et n'importe quoi
un truc logique à toute logique de père
x rite chauffer recul le père fouras le
le père de pernik a le permis car le
tournis qu'à regarder la réponse vous
êtes une vraie famille
c'est une vraie famille fort boyard vous
connais vous nous aviez dit que vous
aviez même un petit surnom pour le père
fouras la four est j'appelle four est
oui c'est vrai j'ai comme ça il y en a
plein d'autres qui l'appelle foire est
aussi parce que quand c'est bon ça c'est
même âge et s'est propagé
[Applaudissements]
une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle on va
commencer
la bonne nouvelle walid tu gagnes le
scooter
[Applaudissements]
là
le sculpteur ouais il est ce que tu es
content moshi au wave est ce que tu as
un mot à dire à matthieu delormeau avant
de partir ce que c'est merci ça irait
wade
toutes mes condoléances à matthieu
delormeau
[Musique]
pas mois que nous serions pas moi le
scooter c'est gagné pour toi allez ça
c'était la bonne nouvelle la mauvaise
nouvelle
mathieu j'ai des règles j'ai des
huissiers qui sont là quel c est ça qui
me regarde je peux pas annoncer quelque
chose et pas le faire derrière ces
bonnes bases
alors
attendez voilà et là c'est souvent mieux
mâchoire
c'est rien c'est rien
c'est là
savoir
cerveau c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
aussi bien calme toi
mathieu oh c'est bon c'est bon
merci jean mathieu mathieu c'était votre
voiture
non mais c'est vrai a bien sûr que c'est
sa voiture est bien de gens oui c'est
votre voiture mathieu ne vous inquiétez
pas on va lancer un appel ensuite on
avait même semé même pour cette voiture
j'ai le coeur qui bat mathieu on a
quelque chose à vous montrer c'était
votre voiture bien sûr et votre voiture
c'est terminé maintenant fête de tirs au
but
bien sûr que c'est votre voiture mathieu
mais mathieu c'est pas une on n'est pas
des monstres quand même regarder la
transformation de votre voiture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petrov une voiture à la casse une
voiture qui était morte et on l'a
reproduit à la paf auteur cette voiture
c'est elle est à l'identique de votre
voiture donc en fait c'est juste de la
tôle
voilà mon père amateur
pour moi c'est un peu soupçonne vannes
c'est parce que franchement le cuir
rouge comme ça sans aucune pouvait être
que la nièvre est basse et un mandat on
l'a reproduite vous dis à l'identique
merci steve
merci bien sûr on n'a pas massacré vie
la voiture de leur donner une autre
voiture qu'une voiture là c'est juste de
la tôle
elle était déjà morte la voiture voilà
mon matthieu delormeau applaudissements
polis parce que matthieu delormeau il
s'en sort bien mais à l'un d'entre vous
qui on va aller dans un restaurant où il
ya déjà des animaux via la compagnie
créole
il ya une cinquantaine de personnes qui
sont chez cette personne en train de
danser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous nous avez demandé de revoir trois
ans de délire sur d8 s'est tout de suite
la partie toujours le hashtag le hashtag
la personne donc chez qui nous sommes et
vous pouvez gagner donc une xbox voilà
ce soir bien sûr on vous appellera tout
à l'heure je vous le dis la personne
sait qui on est elle est par là c'est
tout le monde sauf mathieu
ah non mais j'y ai cru de ouf et je vous
le dis c'est pas dit non plus gillon
s'occuper de vous dans un instant vous
inquiétez vous avez demandé de revoir
trois en délire avant qu'on voit ceux
qui ont déjà tant de voir la tête de la
personne ça va être magique un des plus
gros délire qu'on a eu dans tpm paix
vous nous avez demandé de revoir la
partie de cache cache bien sûr c'était
avec gad elmaleh arnaud ducret et kev
adams était le 9 juin dernier
alors vous avez montré les images d'un
enfant mais là on a vraiment repris le
cache cache
on avait tous huit ans et demi ce
n'était vraiment n'importe quoi regarder
c'est la première fois je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'on va faire un cache-cache
géant non
[Applaudissements]
cette émission était pas
ilan bagages s'est trouvée j'en ai
trouvé ça allait trouver il faut que
c'est trop tôt dit regardez regardez la
dernière j'en ai trouvé deux j'en ai
trouvé de jean-michel mais retrouver ses
bonnes et par monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est par vidal non parce qu'ils
demandent quand tu démarres le tournage
on va la faire cette émission juste
légal excusez moi il est en cavale
améliorera mina mais on l'a trop bas
coûts
c'est énorme
ok merci merci à gaz on l'a eu
on est monsieur un très gros fous rires
sur des beats qu'on voulait vous vous
traitiez pas si vous avez ce que vous
allez regarder le grand bêtisier de noël
avec bernard montiel et justine fraioli
ils ont eu un fou rire s'enrayer vous
êtes obligés de regarder ces partis
wawel son bateau bull bernard merci
justin on tient plus à son quart 11
comme j'aime évoquèrent l'ong goal à
lilongue voit son bec soboul bernard on
vous dira mme angle elle est tellement
longue
écoutez on me le dit souvent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un petit regard externe explique
qu'il vous a fait marrer cette année sur
des huit ans maria sur d8 ya un truc qui
me fascine c'est voyage au bout de la
wii ça c'est fou ça ça c'est incroyable
ils font des belles paires de marché
cela dit vous savez qu'ils font ce genre
du 10% fin ça ça marche bien et en fait
il ya il s'est passé des trucs
incroyables a un qui sont endormis et là
il y en a un qui en dix ans a carrément
perdu la page de son livre à dire savait
plus où il en était c'était bien on a
l'image mais c'est ces partis regarder
la formidable
sans compter les chances de devenir oups
c'était parce que je ne fais j'ai fermé
les livres donc il faut que je retrouve
ma page je suis je suis désolé cc c'est
particulier ça c'est n'importe quoi
alors atteint on en était juste avant ça
ou en étions-nous et ben encore plus
loin on était dans la deuxième partie un
chapitre 3 ou 4 par là ya pas une table
des matières je ne sais plus ce que j'ai
vu voilà partie 2 les esclaves premier
chapitre un lever de soleil
[Applaudissements]
maintenant il a fallu poser mention pas
je passe à autre chose mais c'est un
hasard du coup aujourd'hui qu'elle soit
en panne et qu'aujourd'hui c'est ma
place elle disparaît aujourd'hui je la
confie à quelqu'un elle tombe en panne
et c'est exactement la même et le cuir
c'est une exclusivité jeunesse
oui on a compris merci c'est merci donc
le tueur c'était une excuse c'est ça
c'est bien ce que je pensais voilà allez
on accueille aubert 3g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez revenir sur quoi et bien sûr
les ratés les émissions qui nous ont
quittés un petit peu trop tôt parce que
ce soir c'est quand même la mégateuf des
8 à 3,1 et tpm paix fête ses 6 ans sur
la chaîne
oui oui on a compté six risques en
addition tous vos déplacements sur
l'horaire au quotidien en 3 en effet six
personnes dans le public mais moi je
vous dis six ans tpb en fait parce que
juste avant qu'on démarre la chronique
je voudrais vous montrer juste une porte
une porte et peut-être que quelqu'un va
reconnaître son appartement un regard
différent s'est plaint des ja le patron
n'ouvrait pas il ya une fête énorme
elle fait énorme je vous le dis il ya
des animaux dans la cuisine
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quoi répond
quoi qu'est ce qu'il a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
pas de quoi mon chéri qu'est-ce qu'il
était persuadé qu'on n'arrête pas de me
dire de but à l'heure ouais
camille c'est vous reconnaissez votre
porte alors oui c'est pas du tout des
portes en bois massif comme ça il a
plein tu es en chalet d'habitation et
camille à quelqu'un chez vous ben y'a
personne mais je comprends même pas
qu'on pourrait avoir laissé ya quelqu'un
t'a chiens et gagne un chez moi là bas
il ya quelqu'un chez vous la hap à mon
avis elle avait les cambrioleurs alors
qu'ils sont faits passer pour vos
parents yakhi chez moi y'a pas être chez
moi et qui nous avons fait un nom pareil
y'a personne non les personnes seront en
fait elle est aux parents mais c'est
grâce à lui qu'on est rentré vous avez
gauche auprès des clés de mes parents
dans le sud et gare on verra la corde en
un instant ça tombe bien un truc je suis
un des seuls à voir ton adresse pas
[Applaudissements]
et
il faudrait la passé alors demeco c'est
pour un déménagement
j'ai pas grand chose j'ai pas grand
chose ne vous inquiétez pas on ouvrira
la porte dans un instant j'ai hâte de
voir l'état de l'appartement de camille
combal
on va être bien quoi qu'est-ce qu'il ya
bébé on a vécu tellement de choses là
dedans bien l'avouer les chaleurs droits
des animaux et tout bois et des animaux
et où il ya des animaux il va passer une
bonne chronique c'est bon les gars là
quoi comme ingénieur est ce qu'on peut
me dit j'ai un canapé rouge c'est une
excuse
là
camille a mis à l'écart il dit la vérité
le pauvre il a eu peur je vous dis on a
reproduit regarder on a repris votre
hall d'entrée votre email
c'est à l'identique mais ça n'est pas
chez vous non ça on n'a pas pu le faire
c'est vraiment chez vous là c'est
vraiment mieux allez on y va on commence
à connaître
je suis mal pour camille que sarah
kamini lisa j'avais peut-être qu'en
fait-on m'ouvrir ya rien de ces que du
mytho pas les animaux non mais peut-être
camille peut-être que je vous fais
marcher depuis le début car rien ne se
passe rien chez vous il faut quand même
penser à ses voisins qui regardent par
l'oeil de boeuf équivaut la compagnie
créole cheveux
été acquis via la compagnie
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on se calme un peu
on a un chronique de bertrand galway
souligna jean luc lemoine qui mariait
juste après les questions 4/3 h 15 pause
juste montrer une photo
parce que gilles verdez va réaliser un
énorme défi en dernière partie de cette
émission
gilles vous avez réalisé dé définir dans
cette émission non non non vous partirez
à ce que sexy dans tout l'immeuble de
dix sept ans arrêtez-vous l'angoissé
c'est ça les yeux bandés
non parce que il ya des problèmes d'air
non mais c'est vrai faut vraiment essayé
les lunettes
jack c'est vrai mais c'est quoi comme
appareil si la décence et le plus grand
toboggan du monde
le lpg t m dans un instant sur des mines
ce soit que je vais mourir de rire
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes formidables
on
pasionaria spa belgique vous avez fait
vivre des moments exceptionnels
tu as d'ailleurs pour le plaisir voulait
pas qu'on voit givre quantité le cadre
on va voir d'abord la piscine ce que
c'est un grand deux des huit voies là et
après le canon et après vous irez faire
votre nouveau défi mais là ça sera pas
la même limonade
non mais je vous le dis ça alors puisque
aujourd'hui vous allez faire un vrai
défi mais j'ai vu le truc là moi mais
juste en dessous il y aura le gâteau
normalement casser une bougie et vous
allumerez le gâteau et que vous n'êtes
pas des stars y aura le gâteau en
dessous du seuil qui sépare sa séance
est vraiment c'est sécurisé il ya aucun
problème
d'accord mais nous avons des bouts de
gilles et c'est bon rappelez-vous de
gilles s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
rappelez vous de gilles quand gilles
frappé oui la piscine la piscine s'était
fait garder rien il voulait sauter là
combien de temps on est en sécurité
je saute je me lève ton bts ton bep du
sceau de genève m étais sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
un moment
on se reverra pts alors ses plus beaux
jours et la chaleur là il va faire
vraiment un vrai défi gami vous le savez
il ya des gens qui sont allés chez vous
il ya le patron de dévit cerveau le
directeur général de l'élite qui est à
la porte de chez vous avec la compagnie
créole oui exactement
les animaux dans l'instant on aura
également jean-luc lemoine dans nos voix
pour les quatre tiers mais pour
l'instant avant de faire la chronique de
bertrand parce que pendant votre
chronique on enverra gilles se mettre en
place pour le défi du toboggan
camille est ce qu'on voulait voir ce qui
se passe chez vous franchement non les
gars javier est ce que vous attendez
vous à des stadiers si vous m'entendez
fait un signe de la tête
après il m'a dit je me dis qu ancien je
sais lire sur les lèvres du panneau on a
quand même le seul patron qui a contrôlé
l'histoire jeune homme brillant 4e de
mail
il est tout jeune le gâteau j'ai tout
jeune tout jeune et déjà est déjà si
talentueux devait m'envoyer que camille
combal à une porte en chêne véritable
nom mais sur une faute de la partie
s'achève ou quoi
un fait bien il ya un restaurant de
raclette ou quoi je vis dans un resto
d'altitude allez c'est génial oliva et
d'un petit coeur allez bon clavier on va
pénétrer chez camille combal avec la
compagnie créole c'est parti mon que ça
dure on rentre on va voir ce qui s'y
passe c'est vraiment j'ai vu un cas il
faut le dire aux téléspectateurs mais
vraiment chez moi
tara show car il a les clés de chez vous
lui tranquille à sa vie serait sa vie au
ranch et camille combal papa a volé
auparavant il ya eu là j'ai mon verdict
pour calaisien
il
l'ambiance et qui tous ces gens là
à
allez dans la cuisine l'égard des
animaux
ce sera fort les mecs soient éclaboussés
fois longues années les 7 la fatigue
amérique il avait ses trois années mais
bravo les gars on va passera tout à la
bagarre s'en foutait là qu'on voit les
crânes sont de toutes les fêtes à gaby
combat
[Applaudissements]
mon quartier
ton les gars quoi les motos et les gars
c'est un truc d'altitude mais enfin
quand même car on vous a pris une
chambre d'hôtel pour ce soir bien sûr
pas vous a pas ce qu'ils vont inciter à
bas toute l'année mais les voisins ils
doivent être entretenues bail qui a des
gros problèmes avec les voisins corps
mais obtient ici c'est généreux dit
c'est pour ça julien vous allez avoir
beaucoup d'appels de demain avec ton
syndic tu vas t'amuser
bon bah voilà donc laissé qui tous les
gens que ce n'est pas ces gens on allait
survenir en bas de chez vous c'est des
gens on les connaît pas mais on les aime
beaucoup sa défense tout ça d amour de
garde
ils vont revenir chez moi oui allez mon
cas mais vous l'avez vous couchez bas
dont la soeur du poète vous
accueillerons jour ça je vais demander à
gilles d'aller se mettre en place pour
le défi du toboggan le toboggan humains
dans un instant avec gilles verdez ça va
être fou
restez avec nous gilles va prendre de
gros risques à giuly parce que c'est lui
qu'on a choisi pour faire le togo rue
main
c'est le plus grand toboggan du monde
offre à mentir et on l'a installé sur le
toit de des vite il va dévaler fouet à
la fin il y aura le gâteau c'est lui qui
va nous faire découvrir le gâteau deux
des huit avants bien sûr d'accueillir
jean luc lemoine qui viendra nous voir
pour les questions en 4/3
allez mon bertrand win ce qui a été
ratée se réveiller
plus ça va plus je vois la tête des gars
autour de la table font arrogants si
génial qu'est ce qu'il ya à faire une
tomographie génial c'est le gâteau en
bac est gênant mais il ne prendra pas il
va juste arrivé le gâteau opéra voilà
c'est ça dimanche la fête
d'accord j'ai compris oui oui la
mouvance gym en tout cas le toboggan
c'est génial c'est une des phrases qui
restera de ces prêts
mais tous ces jeunes ont tout ça mais
c'est beaucoup la garderai chez vous le
toboggan c'est génial ou à l'efb début
j'en suis bada
de 8 à 13 ans trois ans de programmation
forte du jamais vu sur la tnt car on a
tendance à l'oublier mais là l'ambition
de la nouvelle grande chaîne à sa
naissance en 2012 c'était ça on veut
être une grande chaîne donc on va
proposer des programmes événementiels
fort oui surtout est inédit et c'est
vrai qu'en trois ans la promesse de
programmes inédits a été entièrement
tenues avec la mise à l'antenne des
missions jamais vu ailleurs comme à
prendre ou à laisser le maillot nouvelle
star pop star friends navarro femmes de
loi et l'inspecteur barnaby non vraiment
que de l'inédit mais je voudrais pas
gâcher la fête avec mon mauvais esprit
ciel parce qu'en trois ans effectivement
des 8 a mis à l'antenne des programmes
inédits qui auront à tout jamais marqué
l'histoire du paysage audiovisuel
français et des parts de marché surtout
merci de ne pas applaudir ce soir toutes
nos pensées les plus émues vont à adam
recherche un rêve
amazing grace une maman formidable
oui c'est vrai ça on allait oublier sa
vers la politique
undercover projet fashion et les rois du
barbecue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'évacue tous les sites où son site elle
en plus sérieuses et cela juste julia
parce qu'il ya des téléspectateurs qui
nous redonne de plus en plus franchement
je quand vous avez vendu sa démission
écoute
j'aime bien parce que les rois du
barbecue z et avec gérard va tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors dès septembre avait aucune chance
de salon septembre ouhlala merci oui
c'est en automne il a battu en automne
sur les bras dans une porte
est-ce qu'on peut aller la tuque et je
crois qu'il est temps d'aller coucher
tati 1
est-ce que j'ai été voir le patron de
2,8 yayi tu l'as vu quoi mon barbecue
[Applaudissements]
pas mal c 'est bien derrière moi je joue
bien je tirais sur cette île oubliée
allez viens on pouvait pas fêter les
trois ans de la chaîne sans évoquer le
programme qui occupe plus d espace dans
la grille de 18 juste derrière la pub
touche pas à mon poste
alors en trois ans seraient les
mauvaises langues se sont déchaînés on
nous a notamment accusé d'être hanouna
dépendants ou encore d'avoir trop tirer
sur la corde tpm p c'est faux j'ai re
visionner les trois ans d'antenne on a
décliné la marque tp mp3 quatre fois
grand max avec touche pas mon frère me
touche pas à mon public et touche pas à
mes héros touche pas mais je tenais
touche mama nouvelle star touche pas à
mon touch pas moi redit son touchera ou
patrick jamais pardonné touche pas à mes
direct suspect mais années quatre-vingt
dix touchent pas les années 2000 et on
attend bien sûr touche pas à mon placo
plâtre
toutefois on peut jacquard et touche pas
à mon pote bourguignon 2,5
le sablar mais ce succès
je suis rentré sur les épaules on va
maintenant faire un co touche pas à mon
poing un tag je suis c'est repose avant
tout sur les épaules d'un homme un seul
vous série pétition une question revient
souvent du moins dans ma bouche et celle
de camille quand est ce qu'ils se
barrent lé pa qui borde elle eh bien
vous avez répondu à cette question sur
europe 1 jacques chirac morandini ce
matin j'ai toujours avec vous qui sait
peut-être que ce sera sans moi l'année
prochaine touche pas à mon poste c'est
bon camille dans un an c'est bon nous
attend non non oui c'est vrai que vous
nous fait le coup chaque année fausse
joie quoi c'est pas impossible que
j'arrête dont dans peut-être dans une
saison et peut-être votre dernière
saison je vais la faire mais c'est sûr
que touche pas à mon poste continuera
son bond vers dernières années de touche
pas à mon poste va peut-être pas ce
dernier animée avant dernières années
[Applaudissements]
mais nous sommes dit le nantais qui vous
voulez mais ne touchent pas l'oreille
comme salem kali calme place à un bon
ami à des moutons dans sa cuisine
c'est chez caby et yagil garde est en
train de se mettre en place un dans le
nôtre toboggan géant
merci c'est trop leur demander j'adore
parce que je veux dire dans mon oreille
fait qu'on n'en parle pas voilà toujours
la fête merci beaucoup aux toits
il a une bonne petite cuisine et vous
avez remarqué le gars qui tient les
moutons absolue jo les bases solides on
le garde matthieu delormeau sur fera
petits pois votre cas c'est la fête bat
son plein et pour terminer ce que
j'aimerais voir un petit mot pour chacun
des chroniqueurs qui a participé à
l'aventuré pmp en trois ans j'embrasse
donc élise chassaing rafales y est me
collard et laurent fontaine sur les
bords des branches au rythme lent ventes
hors antenne à 2h du mat
mais comme chez un mec super sympa j'ai
cassé ma tirelire pour organiser le pot
des anciens de tp n aurai l'occasion des
trois ans des 8 et on s'est éclaté comme
des oufs
quand il y avait tous les vols des 300
gigawatts
des fonds que ce match ça se passe bien
les chronos de manche saison 3 c'est en
tranchée tenu six émissions les enfants
si je sais pas où tu étais écoute pas
vraiment parce que j'étais là mais
l'émission hier j'étais dans le couple
et l'enfant dans le point c'est dur de
se détacher
oui allô à juliette ça va ouais ouais ou
lors s'ajuste pas du tout jeune je leur
demandais mais là si juliette arnaud l'a
été sur la photo de rentrée la tp le
plan d'eau hui 13
ouais il montre tout simplement parce
que je dis aux français leur appel à way
allez à bientôt voir dissous
chic art fair ciel merci au versement de
l'ontario dizaine super bien mais non mr
il va nous
bonsoir oui bon je conçois wilson
embrasse fort aussi voilà y reviendrons
en a plein d'autres qui voulaient
participer mais qui était pas dispo donc
merci c'est très bien ça bravo c'est bon
c'est tout ma passe et tout y est
forcément bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tous les gens sont en train de
partir de chez vous regarde et on va les
voir dans les cordes en ballade robben
était là et regardez ils sont tous en
train de partir voilà ils partent tous
deux chez vous caler la fête est finie
regardez voilà ils sortent tous inde
parce que les voisins un petit peu
gueulé
voilà je vous cache pas qu'à me donnera
tout le monde part de chez vous hélas
hélas je vous le dis ils iront dans un
instant chez un autre chroniqueur
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oh
aller avant de retrouver gilles verdez
dans le toboggan le plus grand du monde
je me rappelle moi d'un truc sur un
prime parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes aussi on vous l'avait dit un
bertrand ce que vous les rappeler de
valérie benaïm dans la cabine du père
tofas avec le gros fous rires aussi pour
m'améliorer en faire ah oui c'est vrai
bah oui regardez à l'est la route à fond
bah vous ne trouvez pas ça s'est passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tension
nous ne céderons pas bien
v
les images la fameuse ça me dégoûte à
nouveau je trouve ça
c'est là
voilà qui se dit à côté de vous moi les
insectes ça me fait rien franchement je
viens on n'avait pas peur des uns ça ici
non non non non
ainsi j'ai donné mon nom n'est pas par
exemple si j'aime pas ah mais non c'est
ainsi c'est des insectes guerrouj
personnalisés j'ai des images qui
prouvent que julien courbet n'a pas peur
des insectes je faisais exprès à gênés
régulière pas dallas l'a amputé rien je
peux me pisser dessus je devais donner
jeu de mail je remets le cas comme ça
j'ai l'élection prend dans la gueule
c'est pas possible j'ai bien j'aime bien
ah oui alors c'est quoi cet indice est
en jeu il y avait de l'aventuré
tout le monde se rappelle que la belle
allée bordée mohamed abbou fermer la
bouche sur aller
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et
bonjour vous regrettez pas de données
sur delta
malgré le peu de dignité qui leur est là
qu il avait fait aussi ce truc là je me
rappelle bien tourner la tête je me
rappelle que si les américains bloqués
là on a perdu la dame on la perd de la
dap et bertrand louchart vous interrogez
pas marché passé un excellent moment
c'est fou rire autistes et magnifique
regarder le oui bertrand installez vous
installez prochain générique c'est parti
[Musique]
allez pour mieux les manières du monde
fantastique énoncé en route pour
l'aventuré
[Applaudissements]
l état bien vertes ont quitté vers 13
heures
ils savent apparemment j'ai rien ça
ouais mais moi je suis je suis une
[ __ ] cet appel c'est ce que met près
de vous remercier ses lentilles voilà je
suis là et face à la savane s'est rien
passé on continue aux côtés des regards
à bertrand
bon ben ça
[Applaudissements]
la plus courageuse fou de foot de fou
mais on n'a pas les images endroit-là en
mai et nora il faut avouer quelque chose
c'est quand même la bombe de débite
c'est vrai oui et est normal nous a fait
des trucs sur le bateau on a que
sélectionné en fait ils ont sélectionné
deux dans ce haut lieu de prendre tous
les trucs qu'elle avait fait aller de
fouras je vous avais pris les trucs où
je ressemble à un petit on va te laisse
à dallas tôt puisqu'il ya gilles verdez
je crois qu'après gilles verdez mongie
doux ou gille ou est ce qu'il est prêt
gilles verdez oh la la
gilles verdez et sur le toit de des 8
gilles verdez dans un instant va faire
un saut incroyable super d'être celui-là
ce que s'alarmer chéri tout l'hiver j'ai
une excuse moi là c'est le flip total à
g vous acquitter d'un fluide
total shell je vais venir vous voir dans
un instant d'accord mon jus on va parler
tout rires oui je vais vous détendre
vous inquiétez pas à manger juste avant
de revoir ça est ce que vous vous
rappelez de l'homme canon avec j'ai
juste on va revoir bonjour jousse est
fort en moi aussi je faisais attention
et vous en verrez chez les gars non
voilà faites ce que vous dites monsieur
tout se passera bien
vous êtes tous monsieur il est parti est
parti de monsieur alors j'ai londres a
allumé la mèche du cadeau en [ __ ]
en [ __ ] gillot va allumer la mèche du
calen sayan est allumée gilles vous
allez partir dans un instant du tout je
t'aime tarifs à tout jamais pas tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
illégal
[Rires]
mais je crois que je croyais être plus
drôle parce que c'est le double saut que
[Rires]
la lan aux relations
il craindrait serait-ce que jlm en temps
oui je vous entends cyril oui merci
alors les chéris je reviens vers vous
dans un instant d'accord je voudrais
laisser qu'on laisse un peu gilles s'il
vous plaît voilà qui n'entendent pas
voilà tout ça parce qu'il ya un lien
jean luc qui m'arrivait sur le plateau
qui va nous faire les quatre tiers est
ce que j le montant maintenant voilà
laissez le tranquille tu es tombé le
bien parce que là il va faire un saut
énorme et gilles verdez va faire un saut
énorme
regardez cette photo regarder ce qu'on
va faire gilles dans un instant c'est
vrai qu'on montre la photo vous regardez
bien
gilles il va il va faire voilà un saut
sur le ventre comme ceux ci il va
descendre tout me up 2d vite c'est un
truc fou c'est le plus grand toboggan du
monde
sauf que non mais non et c'est trop bon
sauf que sauf qu'il croit qu'il va faire
le plus grand toboggan de monde s'est
encore invitée mais en fait ça tue le
foot c'est une photo c'est un montage en
fait non il n'existe pas le plus grand
taux
ça vient juste
et en revanche est ce qu'on à la photo
du plus petit toboggan de fois la photo
s'il vous plaît
mourez d'envié
je crois que ça va être encore une
séquence je crois qu'ils attaquent à un
couperet la séquence pas compris tout à
l'heure elle me dit mais je les fais ça
c'est terrible et échos
radis salades et elle aimerait d'accord
voilà moi je joue à les deux et il sait
pas qui croire mais bon ça va sinon
aulas mais c'est lui qui a pas compris
changer les piles de sol automne si aux
plaideurs tirera bien des piles si les
petits trous comme ça d'accord allez on
accueille jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
d'abord mentionné
je suis
enfin camille oui c'était bien je compte
on part avoir participé mois jean-luc
vous allez nous faire des cafetières des
quartiers très spécial sur tout ce qui
s'est passé là tcd qui sait que kennedy
a que 10 des décès depuis la rentrée
oui il va pleuvoir alors quoi
à l'autoriser gilles neau rigide va le
voir parce que gilles on va s'en occuper
dans l'instant juste le temps de revoir
ya une séquence qui nous avait fait
beaucoup rire et c'est vrai qu'il n'aura
vous l'avez fait c'était le ice boulette
chalard est-ce que vous rappeler de ça
vous aimez des boulettes j'en peux plus
de tata côté oui bah merci c'est bon
merci et regarder mais la catapulte non
il ya l'autre collège paul valéry lalime
qui le remet vraiment baume au coeur que
l'on faire attention mais ceux comme la
torre combattants vox a pas neuf
oui c'est ça 3
ah ah
jeudi m
[Rires]
guingamp est essentielle
exceptionnel
pendant ces trois ans déjà révélé du
bonheur et sean hrivnak aura donc des
cafetières les cafetiers incroyable et
4/3 ce sera juste après gilles jaquet
jeudi à du gros dos il ya du gros dos
pour sûr tout le monde on a besoin de
dire surtout besoin de mathieu mathieu
et c'est vrai que ce soir en plus
c'était une belle soirée pôle jules est
ce que tu m' attends mon chéri
oui oui je tente en ciel gilles vous
allez faire un des plus grands sauts au
monde mon chéri vous êtes un héros
mongil ils m'ont dit que j'avais un
masque parce que les dernières personnes
qui avaient tenté ça avait vu ce qu'il
fallait faire avait renoncé en cours en
bas c'est ça non mais c'est vraiment
chez nous c'est vrai mais si vous êtes
le plus courageux de la banque vous le
savez mon fils j'ai le mot chéri je vous
entends ça va toujours mieux je sais
gilles avant avant bien sûr de prendre
place sur le toboggan est ce que gilles
moins cher est ce que voulait me dire un
dernier mot ce que vous voulez dire un
dernier mot aux personnes qui vous sont
chères m
vous savez oui un moment comme ça même
de l'ormeau me paraît supportable
[Applaudissements]
c'est maxime ce qui se passe ici sebalj
gilles on va vous mettre en place à ce
qu'on s'entête remplace gilles les
cherry sur le toit des 8 il va faire un
saut ne sais plus combien de mètres l'un
c'est vraiment je crois que c'est
combien de mètres le de l'auto beau ses
étages
si ces tarifs a tôt pour moi parce que
c'est réparable laura c'est pour moi car
brad va tout bien sûr
jlm était donc la sat assurant là là là
là vous me faites peur pour me fait peur
faites attention faites gaffe à lui
énorme attention là prenez pas de
risques les gars prenez pas de risques
les gars ont fait les gars faites gaffe
les gras mais ne lâchait pas là c'est
pas non mais les gars faites gaffe vous
savez qui me fait peur mais moi j'ai
peur là arrêtez les gars bien sûr de vos
gars là parce qu'ils m'ont les rageux
très longtemps là et même moi parce que
j'ai peur quand même de non sens
charrier parce que je pense qu'ils font
là c'est risqué quand même on sait
jamais je suis pas d'élection sur deux
toiles à une font peur j'ai eu le mettez
vos places
mettez la en place je veux pas voir ça
non parce que ils sont vraiment sur les
touches aller avait été l'auteur mais
mettez l'eau bien en place mais jamais
je lâche mon micro well avec mon micro
la chaleur
merci mettez le en place maintenant pas
se mettre les gens devant comme si vous
étiez sur l'atome au nord comme si vous
êtes sur un toboggan tête en avant nous
allons chez vous comme si le petit
château benoît obtenez bien le toboggan
tu as le mans mais là comme sur un
toboggan
mettez-vous meinau mettez-vous à plat
ventre l'avantagé très à plat ventre
ap le oui à plat ventre bah oui c'est
comme ça sinon il va lui et risque de se
blesser
rigolez pas dire un mot quand même un
dieu un dieu gilles j'ai longtemps
attendez une consigne de sécurité les
juges ne vous sautez pas laissez vous
glisser
d'accord d'accord basse que celle au
point vous faire mal et c'est vous us
qui sait ça va glisser la chaîne hema et
laissez vous glisser de vous souhaitez
pas jeter pas les noms je t'ai pas
[Applaudissements]
kasha
j'ai ça va mieux
voilà bravo sud venez nous rejoindre les
quatre tiers de jean-luc quelle rigolade
déchets escabeau dû revoir le sont en
action avec le son et le sens s'il vous
plaît c'est fou c'est fou
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce c'est le numéro 1 du
segment c pour le garçon ou la fica qui
a imaginé ça quand même championnat
julien qui sont bien sûr les florence 1
voilà qui ont fait un travail magnifique
on s'éclate et meaux jean luc c'est les
questions en 4/3 et gilles va arriver
dans un instant vous inquiétez pas j'ai
pas trop le jeu sera mouillé on a tous à
la la on était tous contents et la genre
et qui va nous enfoncer pour finir la
soirée allait tout de suite une question
bonjour je m'appelle leone pourquoi n'y
at il plus de questions en cas de pierre
est ce parce que vos collègues sont
enfin intelligent ou parce que vous êtes
une grosse feignasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un peu des deux chaires leone je vous
dois vous avouer que j'ai vécu un début
de saison idyllique
car débarrassées des cats hier certains
de mes collègues commençait même à
m'apprécier voilà ça devrait s'arrêter
ce soir à la ola
les mots
[Musique]
josh fattal où vous êtes m'accroche des
couilles
[Musique]
c'est bien obligé de la veux je prends
quoi
non
il a déjà été couplé
[Musique]
on en saura plus qu'à me repère donc si
on nous a bien vu et
dk tiers le série et j'en vis l1
toujours au taquet bah oui c'est reparti
les cafetières donc nouvelle saison
nouveaux chroniqueurs
ah oui d'après des études récentes
études alors battre l'a démontré
l'espérance de vie d'un nouveau
chroniqueur dans l'émission serait à peu
près équivalente à celle d'un homme
faisant son footing sur l'autoroute mais
ça t'arrive 6 quand même à s'imposer
comme matthieu delormeau un à qui on
avait mis une boule en cuir dans la
bouche de la première émission l'a dit
mchugh découpe ses nouveaux camarades
entre émerveillement et consternation
le plus beau c'est son regard s'est
perdue quand il regarde ce qui se passe
autour de lui un ami du même soin gueule
il m'asperge de ça depuis tout à l'heure
le miel la pancarte est parti l'ocp
[Applaudissements]
et de remarquer et nora qui connaît les
missions ne peut même pas lui répondre
on ne sait pas où je suis pas avec toi
je n'ai pas vu je connais pas mais si on
est au cp c'est une vraie révolution
pour mathieu qui je vous le rappelle
était avant sur arte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas la cuba
qu elle était sur nrj12 à bord le mag et
oust quel chien sera à la hauteur
[Rires]
il était habitué à une certaine rigueur
journalistique avec cyril hanouna c'est
la descente quoi la série le buvez une
cannette et d'un seul coup il a eu une
idée de génie
j'aime trouver un jeu parce qu'ils m'ont
mis une canette
mais ils ont tellement cacher je vous le
dis je vous montre un morceau de la can
est celui qui trouve ce que c'est la
canette voilà sur twitter #cannes est et
ben juriens son poids d une bande
planète
alors nous on habille ses fulgurances
mais pour les nouveaux c'est plus dur
pour garder la tête admirative de
matthieu delormeau pendant que cyril
crée chaque canette et ben jeu lyonnais
[Applaudissements]
pascal
[Musique]
cindy le mec rien génératif assez serré
au bout du rouleau est au bout du
rouleau le live à ses habitués pour nous
l'arrivée de mathieu c'est une embellie
enfin quelqu'un qui réfléchit dans
l'équipe en fait celle qui parle le
mieux des qualités de mathieu senora
j'ai oublié mon endroit non j'ai bossé
dans la tête tous types comme moi bon
nrj 12 était suffisant
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on s'est bien passé oui oui de
temps vous voulez qu'on fasse rentrer
gilbert bel oui très bien
ils apprennent un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait jean reno de torino joris
[Rires]
autorise donc jean reno dans le grand
bleu savarino ça va vous avez peur mais
en plus dans la voiture il terrifie qu
en italie c'est une attraction que
personne n'a jamais voulu faire et tout
arrive là tu es fou liquéfié prochain
prime vous offrez une vraie ya que quand
je vous écoute que ça va merci vous
m'apaiser apg vous vous inquiétez pas
vous avez des doutes sur gilles verdez
aurait d'ailleurs des petits trucs qui
traînent en bas qui les chantent i dit
jamais rien soit on abat vous allez voir
il a bien changé suis déçu donc on a vu
il extrait sur nrj 12
maintenant au moins on est sûr que
mathieu va pas y retourner et pourtant
vous allez voir la tentation est grande
[Musique]
dir c'est une reine il fait mine de
partir de respecter notre hymne au
comptoir
ses larges et 12 km en peignoir le kite
en peignoir dans l'est du sud comme ça
dès l'amont mathieu je sens que c'est
une très bonne recrue pour les quatre
tirs c'est énorme c'est ma nouvelle
idole et surtout ne croyez pas que
mathieu est malheureux chez nous au
contraire il a trouvé nouvelle famille
et avec cyril un nouveau papa toujours
prêt à lui donner des précieux conseils
étaient vraies h mise c'est foutu de
conforter chemise comme est possible
plus au maire de sceaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiens
ces canaux merci j'ai pris c'est
pourquoi verser alors mathieu c'est
aussi une sensualité débordante
il a essayé de draguer et n'aura à cyril
valérie bénaïm et ils se comptent pas
s'arrêter là regardez les nerfs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
venez vite les méchants je serai encore
avoir des pipits ce soir là méchant
gilles verdez ça cache quelque chose
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire la vérité
et à l'antenne gilles et isabelle se
cherche mais pendant les pubs c'est
autre chose
elle était sèche et vous allez voir les
yeux ouais ouais ouais
allez bonne quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
erica est choqué mais elle aussi essebi
turin faute il faut dire que eric ané
n'aime pas la méchanceté mairie klm la
gentillesse et élever des poules chez
elles et donc toutes les qualités pour
intégrer notre émission isabelle est
content de son arrivée car elle a enfin
trouvé quelqu'un pour écouter ses
anecdotes
enfin presque
déjà parce que les princes appel à
témoin
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
il ya des choses qui bougent pas cette
année encore ils allaient morini-bosc se
prend des vents mais pas que isabelle
c'est aussi des accidents qui ne peuvent
arriver bac à elle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à ces problèmes quand tu prend l'apéro
avant l'émission lors d'une cabine à
bloc nous recevions julien lepers en
batman ah oui y'a pas longtemps ça bah
oui c'était pas longtemps le problème
c'est que julien a pris un peu trop son
rôle à coeur mais qu il a vu isabelle il
ya cru que c'était le joker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on fait du son
je veux faire ça n'a rien à [ __ ] dans
les nouveaux il ya aussi eric dussart ah
oui enfin lui c'est particulier c'est
particulier c'est un ancien qui était
déjà avec nous sur france 4 avec jean
michel fetsch chérie c'est si bon de
retrouver des amis
c'est tout à votre honneur vous savez ce
qui me fait plaisir ce qui après quatre
ans d'absence je vois qui à tour c'est
pas de petite ambiance père pour y
rentrer tout le monde n'avait pas changé
du tout ah oui bah
[Applaudissements]
elle et qui sera aussi affecté lui qui
va fournir toutes les images de
l'émission on a pris un professionnel
style sa tâche pour autant on peut le
dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu j'ai deux images des états misé
dans l'armée mais je voulais sortir donc
d'accord quel bon camarade sociale gérée
et quel chien il n'a pas changé
hélas on leur bras de l'assuré en tout
cas en plus il nous a inquiétés ya pas
longtemps vous savez on a disparu 48
heures il ya deux semaines à jean michel
jarre et on est et on n'était pas bien
ils donnaient tout ce qu'il avait bien
pu lui arriver mais si reed avait sa
théorie on n'a pas de nouvelles de jean
michel
personne n'a de nouvelles de jean michel
personnes peut-être qui sait pas qu'elle
qui l'a bouffé un cuba frais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit conseil pratique avant d'en
bouffer à la date de péremption série
connais bien cette équipe car il aime
vraiment ses chroniqueurs il échoue
shoot donc avant chaque émission y
trouve toujours un petit mot pour les
motiver et surtout les valoriser 10h au
compte on vous voir et c'est encore sur
leur portable encore à à refaire le
monde
quelle bande de cuvées re un peu blanchi
la [ __ ] télévision
senna
sacré tout peut se faire que s'il ya
d'ailleurs à travailler tout l'été pour
revenir plus forts meilleurs à la
présentation est là où il a beaucoup
progressé
si tant est que ce soit possible c'est
sur sa capacité à tenir les surprises
regardez c'est besson vous ne savez même
pas vous qui est l'invité demain
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment une surprise
qu'elle fait aucune télé et elle a
décidé de venir nous voir
fall dit eh oui vous le dis pour le
moment je voudrais vous dire que forever
john club a donc tous est en tournée
dans toute la france au palais des
congrès de paris du 3 au 5 décembre et
au zénith de paris le 14 février car on
sort des airs en bois dit merci à vous à
voir avec le mercier se gare ouverte qui
sort la version choisie et demandera
loana qui sera avec nous
[Musique]
à présent il y aura loi d'accès avec
nous et ça c'est fait ça s'est réglé
dans les 10 secondes c'est un record je
prends plus mais touche pas à mon poste
ne serait pas rien sans des invités
c'est a déjà commencé sur les chapeaux
de roue avec la venue de guests
prestigieux comme aymeric vous vous
souvenez d'amérique ah oui aymeric ex
candidat de secret story pour le plus
grand plaisir des nora et d'isabelle
morini-bosc bon on a eu une altercation
ensemble dû donner la faute ce sera un
peu lourd je suis sûrement aussi pour
quelque chose que j'ai fait du mal être
trouvé qu'elle soit plateau en pointe ou
annoncés sur ses calanques ornent encore
ouvertes on se faufile que en année par
ailleurs si aymeric je voudrais dire
merci d'avoir été avec nous mais j'aime
voir dans ton émission radio
[Applaudissements]
notre message
mettez moi ce que j'aime beaucoup et
briquet il aime beaucoup les méchants
c'est un garçon très long qui est oui
mais vous êtes vous et l'émission nous
on a le droit de vous même pas c'est
qu'on se rencontre pas être non voilà la
recette se perd mais c'était mon nom
d'années on était vraiment un garçon
sympa d'ailleurs je vais aller faire son
émission de radio
mais c'est bien pour vous c'est bien
parce qu'il va bien vous allez recevoir
c'est ce que je vais faire sans rigoler
je vais filmer et je vais les amener
avec moi les deux ont fait une ovation
sa revanche sur le quadra salut bonjour
assure ça ça se passe pas toujours comme
ça avec les invités la semaine dernière
nous recevions pour la première fois la
délicieuse virginie ledoyen
oui mais que cyril adore il a dit dans
l'émission et qu'il ferait tout pour
elle jean-michel aussi il aime bien mais
pour d'autres raisons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je pouvais je vous disais droit mais
ça veut dire enlever la poussière ou une
partie et si virginie nous regardons
embrasse moi non plus je me sens très
fier sont très grande actrice est très
joli et voilà alors cherchez l'erreur
puis c'est la classe oui mais je vais
vous rassurer et regarde pas l'émission
astuces arrière pas l'addition est mené
pour la première fois dans l'émission
j'ai regardé parce qu elle s'était
renseignée mon avis dit de se méfier de
la blonde assise à côté de moi
la teigneuse non sauf que manque de bol
c'était caroline ithurbide qui étaient
là bas caroline bad est moins dangereuse
et surtout et un prénom plus simple que
l'autre a que comment il s'appelle déjà
mais c'est non
[Musique]
maintenant qu'est-ce que je laime
socrates jamais méchante en plus avec
les artistes les non pas les artistes
pas les rebelles jamais mes actes et
virgile audrey je suis en plus
particulièrement admiratif de cette
jeune femme est en revanche n'en parlons
pas gaston bellemare franks à c'est un
copain dans l'équipe et aussi nadège
tout le monde croit chroniqueuse mais
qui en fait est juste en cure dans
l'émission nous ferons un point sur
l'avancée de son traitement
[Musique]
s
allez messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la championne
l'équipe s'il ya aussi faire entrer
d'espagne cette année on l'appelle à huy
une femme très brillante
quel dommage qu'on la comprenne pas ce
soir je veux avoir une pensée pour elle
car on verra à fréquenter la candidate
du loft mais candidats de secret story à
penser que plus rien de grave ne pouvait
lui arriver
et pourtant la bonne camarade elle m'a
proposé une soirée assez pour que la
gueule le problème c'est qu'on l'avait
assise à côté de erika moulet game la
gentillesse vd poule et thierry moreau
qui n'aiment pas la gentillesse mais qui
aime élever des poules
regardez la détresse et la solitude
d'angela oui
à 16 heures ces sortes de 6 à l'e10
reste leader de toi j'ai cette année
majeure de ne pas non et en demander
non
vous savez
tous étaient légers et des poules d'un
danger d
grosse soirée
[Applaudissements]
l'autre moment de solitude du moins
c'est pour le nouveau jeu vous donne un
indice il est grand blond et vient de
changer de classe cp oui c'est gagner
c'est matthieu delormeau au regard des
sentiments de solitude va regarder
quelqu'un qui a pris le son propre cas
pas tout de suite notre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils l'aiment beaucoup moi aussi mes
chroniqueurs ont des micros tout le
temps le problème c'est qu'ils oublient
souvent donc on les entend coulisses et
là je suis tombé sur un truc non mon
dieu deux chroniqueurs ont vécu disons
quoi à un moment intime non
oh là là oh la la
[Musique]
tu vois bien fort ça a chauffé est sûre
si votre sens que c'est dur mais c'est
pas un jeu alléchant qui s'est alors
mais j'ai peur qu'après comme ça
refroidisse thème algérie alors c'est
par notre cerveau chan double exigence
ça faisait du bien rapide et violent
[Applaudissements]
mathieu et des chants du combat vous
laisser faire a priori valérie a changé
du tout au tout quand même un bon aller
mais les mecs buriné russie qu'à la
patache non elle se lance dans les
bellâtres poilu comme débit des
recherches ou bien j'ai quand même
trouvé quelques images qui allait avec
merci votre honneur
[Musique]
tu vois bien force a achoppé sur des
votants c'est dur mais c'est passé cinq
saisons à rennes
[Applaudissements]
elle eut le culot soit pas dire mais la
foi ou utiles vers des torticolis et
s'est pas précipité bon c'est un peu
émoustillé j'ai quand même des vraies
images hot à vous montrer non 6 alors ça
c'est passé en plateau sais pas si les
enfants sont couchés car attention gros
dossiers non j'ai des images d'isabelle
morini-bosc en train de faire l'amour
avec un panda on y va
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
mais bon là on la préfère c'est quand
même dansé dans ce cas où on aimerait
rentrer le retour de danse avec isabelle
moret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça qu'ils ont déjà
tiens dans cette chanson
[Musique]
information
m
[Musique]
la gagnante
ça génériques
[Musique]
ah oui
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais quoi merci jean luc lemoine
pour ces trois ans qui a été
exceptionnel à paris
[Applaudissements]
jane dernière surtout ces dernières se
présente on a créé les chéri j'ai une
dernière surprise pour vous bien sûr on
va offrir 8 x box à des personnes qui se
sont inscrites 1 sur twitter voilà ça va
partir ça tout de suite
il ya une dernière président surprise
voilà ça va partir jouer remercie bien
sûr tous les animateurs deux des huit
voies l'aller les animaux de la 8 bien
sûr directement au congrès dont les
gagnants bradfort toutes les personnes
qui peaufine direct depuis 20 ans voilà
ça s'est super bien sûr mon juju combes
et tous les jours qui fait tout voilà
sur des beats juge why i fé toi avec qui
elle élève ses trois régions et bien sûr
remercier tous les gens qui nous font
confiance assure des visites voilà
depuis maintenant bas ceux qui étaient
là avant donc rodolphe belmer ara
aprikian bien sûr et puis bien sûr
maxime saada a maintenant qui
travaillent avec nous ouvrez remercie
également au sein des grands dont franck
appietto qui est un bonheur qui pésent
épouse le daily que ce soit 2,28 à
l'étranger sera elle bien sûr toutes les
équipes
régis aussi de délits il se serait remis
d'agrément le seuil des enfants
fort et depuis trois ans il régale et
faire un direct tous les jours que vous
dire très pas évident lévesque sont
vraiment géniaux voilà je voulais
remercier le public aussi qui nous suit
depuis trois ans tout le public qui
vient aussi bien sûr toutes les
personnes qui travaillent sont les
missions sebaoun bien sûr car la vie
bien
[Applaudissements]
qui nous d'aller chez tous les joueurs
de rythme on embrasse par mon ordi
nautique et travaillait depuis sept
années qui flattera exceptionnel qu'on
aime tous les auteurs bien sûr ils sont
avec nous si fier benjamin que je suis
voilà des mythes à trois ans et on va
vous offrir un cadeau le shérif alors
l'équipe après 37 à 35 bateaux parce
qu'il ya des
[Applaudissements]
on peut nous appeler
applaudissements c'est pas le doubs ce
qui va se passer mais pas en bouche
c'est une connerie ce week-end surprise
dans le gâteau qu'est ce qui sert à
crise qui plombe je pense à khelcom bas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse à
bologhine donc il faut que je tape
dessus pour que ça s'ouvre
[Applaudissements]
m
tout cela est normal jusque là peu
importe en fait des trucs
extraordinaires le tout et ce sont les
ja but et on a le plus aimés dans toute
l'histoire des huit dont vous voulez
qu'ils soient là bon anniversaire
[Musique]
petite surprise aux notes hiver de
basket à tous publics on a tous les cas
échéant
m
il n'est pas venu mais son cousin
mercier doit devenir vous aime tellement
j'espère qu'on nous éclater avec la
belle facette très belle soirée
merci
[Applaudissements]
viva
prudence
[Applaudissements]
quant à nice
merci
[Musique]
à
merci
[Musique]